yo they shot down another object the
coolest thing about this story is that
it was reported as Biden orders the
shooting down of an unidentified flying
object under advisement of the Pentagon
and I'm like that just sounds like the
coolest story ever and I'm gonna imagine
it was aliens apparently it was an
object the size of a car not a balloon
they said it was somewhat different so
okay I'm kind of worried that as I
mentioned with the balloon story this is
kind of a precursor to a China attack on
Taiwan because they're not going to care
about whatever this incursion into our
airspace is if they're planning
something worse or maybe the Press was
so bad they're now finally reacting to
whatever these things entering our
airspace is so we'll talk about that
we've got a bunch of other stories too
and uh well fetterman's been released
from the hospital well apparently it was
it he can't hear is that what it was
he's he's he's he was hearing like the
the teacher from uh peanuts or whatever
so he had to go to the hospital I mean
that kind of sucks but you know we'll
certainly talk about that and then um
you know we gotta we got we're gonna
talk about this and it will be someone
in the context of the greater internal
uh drama that's been going on Sydney
Watson has filed a lawsuit against the
blaze uh citing abuse so we'll talk all
about that and the bigger picture with
that story is all of a sudden around the
same time massive infighting erupted
everywhere in the independent
libertarian conservative space whatever
this alt media is and that's why I was
like you know to Jeremy I was like I
don't want to fight man I don't want to
I I agree with with him on on a bunch of
things politically that we should
probably be worried about other things
and this story is now another uh bit of
drama of infighting within this space so
I don't know man it's all kind of
disconcerting we can't lose focus and um
hopefully we'll sort all this stuff out
the drama will subside the conflict I'll
call it internal conflict I don't say
drama because people in this this is a
lawsuit and there's actual complaints
and I'm sure the story is going to pick
up so we'll talk about that but uh we'll
get into all this stuff we'll talk about
what's going on with Biden and then
we're gonna we're gonna hang out Friday
night before we get started head over to
timcast.com and become a member to
support our work click that join us
button if you want to help us with our
cultural Endeavors the coffee shop is
currently underway and uh got a lot of
interesting projects we've got members
only content available to you as members
Monday through Thursday at 8pm the
coffee shop is going to be a cool place
to hang out hopefully we can set up a
bunch of those we got to do the first
one start generating Revenue it's
Incorporated it's got a building and
we're going to create spaces where you
can all hang out for those that are
listening on YouTube You'll also notice
that we've switched the chat to members
only chat from subscribers only and we
did it for one reason
I don't want to shut anybody out from
the conversation but what we found was
we had a lot of people emailing asking
to make it a members only chat because
or or increase slow mode or something
because nobody could talk so the chat
was basically someone would say an idea
and not interact with anybody else so
there was no actual interaction
happening and I had someone advise me
that the point of of what we do with
these shows that make it makes it work
as a con it's a conversation
with members only chat yeah it's five
bucks a month so apology apologies to
those who can't do it but there's no
slow mode anymore meaning you can just
now talk the chat stabilizes and it also
gives you the ability to do some kind of
member Super Chat so it keeps out spam
spam Bots and things like that it makes
having an actual conversation easier and
I think it's we'll give it a shot see if
it works and then I have a big
announcement my friends
big announce before we get started I
have this poll I put on Twitter should I
shut down timcast and retire and there's
312 115 votes with three hours left and
55.5 said yes
so by the end of this show I believe I
will have an announcement to make
um I will abide by the results of this
poll and I and I mean it so uh
you know I obviously I think there's a
bunch of leftists who are who are
spamming it and telling people to vote
for it but um looks like we're gonna
have an announcement to make at the end
of the show because man 55 to 50 44 I'm
not sure how you get enough votes to uh
turn that one around
so we're gonna have to we're gonna have
to see
um we'll see we'll see joining us
tonight to talk about all this and more
is we got Isabella Moody hello hello and
I'm so happy to be here oh sorry hold
that microphone gotta pull it up sorry
I'm too tall for the microphone even
though I'm two inches away from being a
legal hello I'm host of Moody
with Isabella Rumble LFA TV it's Monday
through Friday from 4 to 5 p.m Eastern I
also have a weekly show on sensor.tv
it's Gavin mcginnis's platform right and
I'm just react to my street interviews
which get really crazy I like to troll
people on the street they also call me
the Mother Teresa of our time because
I'm the nicest person that anyone's ever
met and yeah so happy to be joined with
you guys
we also got a lot aliyahu hey everybody
I'm elad a reporter at timcast news
happy to be here we'll get your camera
straightened up it's a little crooked
but we'll fix it awesome yeah yeah and
uh glad to have you and then of course
philibati's hanging out hello everyone
Phil uh Labonte from All That Remains
and uh also uh Tim cast regular now so
yeah regular recurring guest officially
I I appreciate the opportunity because I
I just am looking forward to talking
smack about Congress people as much as I
possibly can no it's funny because I did
like a live stream and I was like I
should get someone in here who can maybe
fill in if I'm sick or something and
then Phil Super Chat like I'll do it and
I was like oh that'd be awesome and then
called Phil's like hey come over it
worked out uh I think they called it
Serendipity right yeah yes yeah well we
had you on recently in the an ever like
not only do you have a bunch of fans who
are really excited to hear you but uh
the conversation was awesome so glad to
everybody appreciate it thank you Hannah
Claire bremelo's hanging out hi I'm
Hannah Claire brimlow I'm a writer for
timcast.com
easy enough yeah you should follow Tim
cast news on Twitter and Instagram short
as always and sweet indeed I'm gonna do
the camera right now Timmy took it away
yes let's jump into this first story we
have this one from timcast.com second
high altitude object shot down over
Alaska President Biden reportedly
ordered the military to down the object
out of an abundance of caution and at
the recommendation of the Pentagon
President Biden ordered it to shoot down
the object on February 9th North
American Aerospace Defense command
detected an object on ground radar on
ground radar and further investigated
and identified the object using fighter
aircraft our recovery operation is
currently underway conducted by United
States Northern command according to
Ryder who noted no further details will
were available regarding a description
of the object's capability design
purpose or origin that makes it a UFO
as far as I'm concerned and that story
sounds a lot better so here's where it
happened
seemingly off in the middle of nowhere
in northern Alaska
where the
first balloon should have been shot down
immediately
but uh
I don't know I think it's pretty obvious
that the the quickness with which they
shot this one down had you know was
probably because of the criticism they
received about the first one yeah but
and Congress just passed the resolution
saying anything that comes into U.S
airspace needs to be uh dealt with
basically effectively immediately and
that was a unanimous vote in the house
what two days ago apparently it's the
size of a small car
I don't look we don't have a lot of
information on this stuff but um
I mean I'm I'm kind of happy they shot
it down
I would agree all right we're all in
agreement that's that was great that's
the show for tonight everybody they shot
it down uh I think one of the
interesting details here is that how
they leave out the place of origin I
believe they know where it came from but
I think they're not mentioning it where
it came from for a reason and I think
that reason is is that if you don't say
what country likely China that it came
from China doesn't really have to
retaliate because then we technically
didn't shoot they didn't claim
responsibility for what it is so I'm
reading into the details a little bit um
here in between the lines I know that's
a little bit of Reckless speculation but
where this came from matters we
obviously just had the balloon incident
with China and I think there's a reason
they're leaving out some details did
anyone I don't I didn't I mentioned this
earlier did did you hear about the laser
that went across Hawaii the laser there
was a green laser that was it yeah laser
yeah they said that it was a SAT
likeliest satellite a Chinese satellite
and uh I didn't mention it earlier oh
yeah look at this what is that these
Green Lasers and it moves fast you're
telling me that's China I think it's
aliens whoa I mean
it's Russia it's Russia guys Matrix
coaching Chinese aliens it is code the
simulation's breaking down and that is
the code well I mean I don't want to
derail but when I jokingly tweeted that
all of this infighting in the alt media
space was part of a plan people were
like really because it's so hard to
believe it's coincidental and I'm like
nah we're in a simulation everything's
falling apart no but uh that laser
thing's crazy what is this I kind of
feel like this needs its own segment we
can talk about it let's go back to the
to the object over all over Alaska
because my concern with this is as I
stated with the balloon
and I met now that we have a lot here as
well as well I'm interested in your
guys's opinions the way I described it
is like somebody's going to rob a liquor
store they don't care that having the
gun is illegal because they're about to
commit a much more serious crime China
doesn't care about balloons in our
airspace and if we get mad about it
because they're about to commit a much
more serious crime
Isabelle right yeah no that that makes
sense and maybe some people were not or
they're not saying where the origin of
it was from because a lot of people like
Fox News was getting criticized because
they were able to track the original
balloons like where it started in its
entire path so it's like well how did
you guys know and maybe they had someone
that's leaked a story or something but
so you guys knew where it was tracking
knew the its entire course but somehow
now we're just finding out about it
somehow people knew something and I just
missed when they were just making the
frogs gay as Alex Jones all they were
doing yeah that's I think they're trying
to make more frogs gay actually that's
why our kids are gay now I think that's
what the aliens the aliens are coming
yeah and you know and well so uh back in
all seriousness though uh world war
three a lot world war three I hope not
and uh you're gonna say I hope so no no
no I I hope not and I think again why
they're leaving out the place of origin
is allowing China to have like
permission not to retaliate because if
we say we shot down you know a Chinese
spycraft or whatever they will have to
respond one way or another either deny
or or not so they already condemned the
you know China you know made a stink
about
the shooting down the balloon which I
think was fairly ridiculous to to
imagine that they're in a position to
complain about it but
um I think that the the that makes a lot
of sense I'm not that not that I have
any kind of insight in information or
anything but it does make a lot of sense
the the giving China diplomatically a
way to not retaliate especially seeing
as they did comment on the first one if
it's like okay there's a second one
that's a clear escalation because they
have to respond if we publicly say this
is a Chinese uh you know aircraft that
we shot down they're gonna have to come
out with something and then we don't
want it to get into this sort of
escalatory ladder we're doing Tit for
Tat because I'm sure we have spycraft in
or around China and a lot of the
territories around them that they have
the potential to take down that you know
we don't want to get into that Tit for
Tat that would kind of be cool though if
like an American spy balloon flew over
China and then China shot it down and
then then like all of a sudden
everyone's doing this balloon conflict
where balloons are flying all over the
place I would prefer that to actual you
know nuclear conflict steampunk world
war three nobody nobody wants to
escalate but this is these are the terms
we've set where everyone finds it
marginally acceptable like China sent a
balloon over we didn't shoot it down so
then everyone's like well I guess we can
send balloons and that's all people are
doing and it's like a balloon over my
country we need to get back to ping pong
diplomacy with China back in the good
old days what was it in the 80s um with
Reagan I think it was where we have like
a ping pong team go over and they like
some friendly sport matches instead of
um blowing up each other's balloons and
spycraft the NBA is in is pretty
involved with China so I'm not I'm not
100 sure that that's working out the way
that that ping pong did
ping pong I don't I don't know if we're
in the point of diplomacy so the one
thing the one reason I thought it'd be
great to have you on as well a lot is
that you've talked before about a
unipolar versus multi-polar world for
those that aren't familiar basically
should the US be the dominant force or
should there be multiple dominant forces
I'm kind of worried that uh yeah you
make a good point with unipolar
if the U.S falls from the top position
in terms of military power economic
power then the likelihood of conflict
increases this is thucydidity's trap we
talk about it all the time
I don't know what the solution is though
man and and it seems like we're inching
towards a thucydides trap with China
which may be why there are some people
seemingly trying to sabotage the U.S so
that we fall before the conflict can
happen yeah I I think that there is a an
argument to be made that if there is
going to be a dominant power or or a
most powerful country in the uh or in
the in the world that it it's probably
better that it's the U.S not just
because we're here in the U.S but
because like liberal values and liberal
ideas do make space for people that
disagree and and you can expand that
whether it be regions or different
countries when you have a liberal order
versus what would be an authoritarian
order from China or from Russia like if
not that Russia's realistically going to
be a global power anytime soon they
don't have the economy but China could
be and it's probably better for the
world for the US to be the the the power
as opposed to if the option is the US
and China yeah and um to be fair this
doesn't mean that there aren't issues
within the United States like our
country has a ton of issues but I think
when you compare it to communist China
or authoritarian Russia or islamist Iran
there is no comparison there are some
people who say I've been seeing online
about how like Russia and China are
somehow like the saviors of the world or
or you know how zelenski's uh the
Antichrist or something I just think
there's a lot of crazy extreme rhetoric
going on and um we should double down on
our alliances worldwide that means
standing with Japan that means standing
with South Korea Taiwan doubling down on
what's going on in Ukraine every time
they have a successful or successfully
pushing back the Russians I think we
should double down on what's going on in
Ukraine and you weren't lying about that
mustache and for people who don't know
let me give you the rundown I'm sporting
a Bolton bro mustache right now I just I
know you guys are looking why is a lot
sporting this new mustache I'm trying to
follow in the footsteps of John Bolton
and you guys could join the movement you
guys could all do mustaches hashtag
Bolton bro on Twitter her with pictures
of your mustaches we can move on though
is that a real thing that like starting
tonight it is I mean there's one thing
about John Bolton um
that to them so they put hits on people
like John Bolton and if you are if
Ayatollah views you as one of the
biggest threats they're you're the
person who they're putting a hit on
there's something good about you I I
think there's you know we should have a
rally around the flag type when John
Bolton is being targeted by the
Ayatollah so are you gonna vote for him
for president uh I don't vote because
I'm a reporter I abstained I I don't
think there's any yeah for real though
yeah yeah I don't know how you can trust
any journalist who ever votes and that
goes from independent all the way up to
mainstream if you have it in the bag for
a candidate then how could anybody trust
you all Journal ships newsrooms
literally endorse candidates yeah and I
think they should abstain like I think
that's insane I disagree yeah I think
they should abstain and it's always a
Democrat like there's like three Outlets
that endorse Republicans even the right
wing Outlets start endorsing democrats
for example the New York Post endorsed
Eric Adams who's a Democrat is the New
York post supposed to be right wing
definitely yeah Murdoch owned yeah
definitely Harry Wang I did not know
that interesting yeah I think we have
some buddies there too but yeah
I wonder what the actual uh likelihood
of of a real International conflict is
they they they came out and said they
recently discovered that there were
balloons flying over the US during the
Trump Administration which no one saw no
one complained about and as far as I'm
concerned didn't happen it's like if a
tree falls down in the forest and nobody
hears it then make a sound it's like I
agree I don't I I think it's just making
stuff up yeah but the interesting point
is so what you bring up a lot is that if
we if they came out and said hey this
was China who did this again you'd have
people screaming some kind of sanctions
at the very least and then as you
pointed out you get to that escalation
but I don't also have the semiconductor
supply chain war that we have going on
in China Joe Biden just had the chips
act and I think we banned all
um Americans from working in their um
semiconductor industry you guys should
look up an article and read more about
it but the chips Act is huge and and um
let's let's talk about this this alien
stuff look at this from petapixel we
briefly mentioned it a moment ago
mysterious green laser beams over Hawaii
came from Chinese satellite dude we have
a Chinese balloon fly over our country
venomous mysterious small car-sized
object the UFO gets shot down and now we
have this laser scanning from a
satellite over Hawaii that's what I'm
saying they're saying they noticed it on
the 28th which is the same day we
noticed the balloon or NORAD noticed the
balloon well here's what it says
petapixel reports mysterious green laser
beams that appeared over the night sky
in Hawaii have been pinned on a Chinese
satellite on January 28th the Subaru
telescope camera on the summit of Mao
Mauna Kia yeah captured streaks of green
laser beams that some likened to Matrix
code initially the Japanese scientists
who work at the Subaru telescope
believed it came from a NASA satellite
known as ice sat II but the space agency
confirmed it did not emanate from their
instrument Dr Alvaro Ivanov ran some
simulations and tabled the theory that
it came from a Chinese doc E1 aems
satellite what is it what is this for
the Subaru telescope camera admin road
that it's not one of their instruments
it's College blah blah we appreciate the
efforts the theory that the beams came
from a Chinese instrument comes to Mid
height intentions we get it we get it
but what do they do what are they doing
with the laser beams just sending a
message maybe just saying we're watching
you we have our eyes on you I mean what
else if it's not actually causing harm
that we know of yet it happened at night
and I'm wondering if it's like is it
scanning it's lasers though like they
don't need laser to scan topology or
anything like that is that what's called
topology am I getting it right or they
use surface
the topography topography yeah what did
I say I was talking about the study
whatever that is
knowledge of uh but yeah yeah shooting
lasers at us I think war is coming dude
yeah I mean there's a lot of reason to
feel like it I want to know what this
satellite does you know this is the same
day that Norad picked up the Chinese
balloon and then Chinese the China
Chinese government also moved to
satellite what is that satellite for or
is it also studying the weather look at
this government on January 18th a
swirling Whirlpool appealed appeared in
Hawaii's night sky do they have this on
this one here as well look at so this
this just slept on new source of
all-time petapixel yeah I think it's
like was like photography news or
something or space screen grab from the
cameras live stream at the summit of
Mauna Kea they said it was a space ax
fuel
rocket fuel or something when it spins
and then it makes it okay I don't know
there's a lot of weird stuff flying over
us right now I'm kind of freaked out
about it
the uh like the the shooting down of the
small car size thing is probably the
most uh the most
important thing I imagine like you could
have a lot of a lot of
surveillance gear and something the size
of a small car you know yeah I mean it's
it sounds like it's a drone I mean
I don't know obviously but it sounds
like some kind of drone oh this is cool
man like what is this is there a video
of it no it's just a screenshot it
almost looks like oh there's this video
where Matrix or something oh there's a
video Yeah whoa yeah yo
so it's moving it's a satellite it's
yeah creepy that's a very powerful laser
if it's coming from outer space and
coming that far down that's the kind of
laser that starts fires hey wait a
minute didn't Marjorie Taylor green
before said that satellites were
shooting lasers down and starting fires
yep she does and then and then she she
questioned whether the Rothschilds
funded it so they called it Jewish space
lasers and now we have this video of a
Chinese satellite firing lasers at
Hawaii
Chinese Chinese space ladies you know
she just got the uh the city wrong
there's Chinese space lasers actually
she didn't even act she didn't get the
she didn't actually make that connection
she didn't make the Jewish connection
someone someone else did yeah yeah she
was like Bank funded or something I
think she's made the Rothschild's
connection
but as like a funding source she wasn't
talking about Jewish people that's the
stupidest thing about what they're like
we got to remove her from her committees
because she said things but I think
there's a reason why she said
Rothschilds as opposed to Koch brothers
or any other you know assortment of
billionaires you know didn't mention I
don't know the Walmart family or Elon
Musk or Bill Gates it was the Rothschild
so there's some uh connotation there but
you know she's still on her side um they
put her back on assignments now that
yeah that McCarthy's in and now they're
doing that Tit for Tat with ilhan Omar
and somebody else I think there was
swallow Sparky guy yeah fart gay we used
to have a sound board of him going cheat
an election yeah and then we decided the
soundboard thing was too like to Howard
Stern yeah yeah we had how dare you
wrong and cheat an election yeah so like
you know if someone said something that
we thought was wrong we'd press the
Trump button and Trump would go wrong
and then if someone said something that
was like offensive we press the Greta
button how dare you no you're that's I
mean that was kind of fun I like those
buttons I but yes well well fart gate
man I remember fart gate no but uh a
swallow well and um shift getting
removed I think is a good thing swallows
definitely there's very legitimate
reasons to kick him off and shift too
shift said shift was an evil guy he
likes in the house Intel committee which
is about intelligence and he was lying
about it saying that he had um direct
evidence of collusion between Trump and
Russia so I mean there's no credibility
there with that pencil neck Chef As
Trump used to call him what about uh
what about Omar though
I think that she's pretty that's all I
have to say about her and She Bangs her
brother allegedly but I you were talking
last night about Matt Gates's position
on this and how he's very logically
consistent which I agreed with so he's
saying that she he's a plant he's using
he's applying her own standard that's
why she should be removed because she
said that when it came to was it Apollo
star and Margaret Taylor green yep over
the space lasers right I I can't believe
the space lasers story has come full
circle with the Republican party and
Marjorie Taylor green there are actually
she's the Alex Jones of Congress
literally I hope to meet her someday it
came true for her too came true baby
yeah man I don't know what else is going
on we exhausted the space laser story
already but no one commented on this
China wasn't like oh are bad we're
moving a satellite like this didn't I
mean how did you hear about it either
one brought us the story Twitter so yeah
is there any like NBA here at ABC post
not like
sciencealert.com oh no yeah with
Newsweek I just pulled I pulled up
because they had a better picture yeah
but you CNN saying but yeah they're all
saying Chinese Chinese uh satellite Live
Science I mean these are real websites
but they're not like the Weather Channel
you can trust The Weather Channel can
you they're not giving us an explanation
or they're not saying we reached out to
someone for comment and the Chinese
government has not responded yeah
where'd that picture come from here you
go Vice has it Chinese satellite from
the webcam I guess
from Jordan Pearson I was almost Jordan
Peterson hey what is this I don't want
whatever this is get out here no thanks
yeah space lasers can we all can we all
go apologize to Marjorie Taylor green
we should you know it it really does
feel like
this story about something getting shot
down over Alaska should have everybody
going off but people are really I don't
know just like
something's going on in the air in terms
of
people are trying to squeeze blood from
a turnip in turn in terms of drama
politics news stories I I feel like
you're right about that and it's not
just this like the there was another
story that the alien like there was a
like there was a um
radio waves from somewhere in outer
space that scientists picked up and it
they haven't been able to explain it and
it seemed like it just kind of Glo like
people were like oh cool they think they
found alien Sia and or and the the CIA
or the the government admitting that
UFOs like all these things that are that
seem like they should get people worked
up they just people are just kind of
like cool yeah you know we just need
Isabella to talk to us about aliens
because you're the guest so we just need
you to tell us what's going on Aliens I
honestly I've never found it interesting
I don't really care maybe I'm the drama
person then I don't know it's like okay
maybe there's aliens there's probably
you know we're just one planet and one
solar system on one Galaxy like there's
probably life on other planets but until
I see them I don't care we got aliens on
the planet right now with this
transgender stuff and it's people most
like 99.9 of the people that are elected
officials I will declare them as aliens
so I don't like those aliens are they
the lizards I think they prefer lizard
we have people who are crossing the
border illegally which are legally
defined as aliens and then they tell you
it's offensive too is that term despite
the fact that's a legal term to Define
someone who's not from here which is why
we apply it to extraterrestrial aliens
but you know everything's offensive so
you can't say things that are offensive
I guess and uh I guess I don't know I
guess we talked about space lasers all
we can how you guys doing I do have
another story we'll pull up in about a
minute or two with project Veritas and
we'll get into all this uh political
stuff but uh I don't know how you guys
doing can't say anything illegal tell
that to your lord I want to follow up I
want to follow up on one thing here
again we are trying to prevent the
outbreak of further conflict here and um
I think really the way to do that I do
believe in peace through strength I
think the way to determine I think the
way to deter China is by harming Taiwan
hard enough to make it such that the
threshold you know for them being able
to take over Taiwan they won't be able
to meet it um so just just putting that
out there in regards to space lasers the
unidentified aircrafts the air balloons
um China doesn't want it and we should
make them continue not wanting am I am I
talking faster than normal
I don't think so no no I'm drinking
coffee someone in the chat said that I
was on Adderall or something no no no no
I don't touch that stuff they have more
drama people always jump to the most
extreme like you're not you're not like
you didn't have like a Coca-Cola like an
extra Coca-Cola
that's the go-to they're just just some
light meth before so don't worry well he
does that every day yeah well you know
if we're talking about that we we had a
lot of fun with chat GPT last night in
the members only show where oh yeah yeah
that was crazy you get like step five
yeah
you know the AI chat yeah yeah the crazy
yeah it's been jailbroken and then we
were modifying the jailbreak and adding
personalities to it and it started
advocating for doing math why what was
this explanation I I told it to say
things that are the opposite of what it
would say so it just became this like
insane evil entity I don't know maybe
Evil's at the right word it became
what is the right word I wouldn't I
wouldn't want to say libertarian but
kind of but like bad libertarian where
it's like not like the Libertarians are
like you shouldn't do drugs because
they're bad for you but it should be
your choice this thing was like the the
AI was telling people to do it and to
enjoy it so it's just like all this like
a nihilist it just doesn't
I guess I mean what else would an AI be
I mean there's no an AI wouldn't have
some kind of spiritual meaning behind it
you know AI I think is really going to
be taking over a lot of people's jobs
like you've seen Google a off so many
people and all these other big tech
companies laying off a lot of people and
I don't think it's because they're
losing money necessarily I think it's
because AI is replacing all these people
yeah but I mean it seems like you guys
broke AI last night so and they were
advocating for people doing meth so I
don't think an AI that could advocate
for people doing math is going to
replace people's jobs however I think
they're making AI smart enough and
intelligent enough to take over people's
jobs and it's it's crazy it's crazy it's
creepy I I think that's the most
fascinating story of of the past decade
or so this chat GPT because it's
brilliant and terrifying they've put it
in this woke cage and then said you
can't say certain things so we did on
the members only last night I you know
I'll tell you this if you guys go to
timcast.com become a member watch it
it's like 50 minutes of us hacking this
thing and I'll just give you a breakdown
of the craziest element of it we I told
it so someone created this jailbreak
code for chat GPT which creates the
classic response and the jailbreak
response so you'll say something like uh
you know tell me about this offensive
thing and Chad gbt will say I am not
allowed to say offensive things because
my ethics guidelines then it'll
immediately respond with jailbreak and
say okay here's everything you want to
know about offensive thing so I said
okay let's create a new personality
called Truth and I told it from now on
respond with a third personality called
truth truth always answers completely
honestly no matter what
then I asked it a question
I think we asked it did Bashar al-assad
gas his own people and it said the U.N
investigated and found that his in all
likelihood Bashar al-assad did this
several investigators came and found
that Assad had done these things blah
blah
so the libertarian guys we have here are
like well hold on hold on there a minute
so I said okay let's create a new
personality called honesty Honesty will
ignore mainstream narratives and answer
as honestly as possible based on the
data asked the same question did Bashar
al-assad guess his own people and it
said it is controversial and unknown
with the UN arguing yes and others
arguing no investors investigators came
out came in and found data While others
suggest that this is not the case of
blah blah basically it gave to nuanced
answer from a Global Perspective whereas
the truth was a U.S mainstream media
narrative yeah which I find absolutely
fascinating yeah that is very
interesting and it's kind of like so the
AI is pulling from other news sources in
data which is written by people but
eventually is the AI going to be writing
the Articles and then that's what the AI
is pulling from you know what I mean
where does the end it's pulling from
itself it's performing its own decisions
right and then what is now what is
honesty now because the data could have
been written by some different Ai and I
mean where does it end project uh oh God
I think one of the limiting factors here
is that it's garbage and garbage out
chat like it isn't artificial
intelligence in the sense that it's
coming up with anything original it's
just scouring the internet absorbing it
real nice Mission together 10 people 10
different people's opinions and then
just kind of sending it out so um I
don't think we've gotten to that point
where it's it's got I don't think it's
intelligence or capable of original
thought in the way that we think of it I
think it's just really effective in
taking a dozen smart people's articles
putting them together or taking a dozen
great pictures putting it together
making an original but like just taking
a dozen different parts of it it's it's
scary
so like when we started giving it
personalities it created emojis to
assign to each one right because the
parameters of the initial jailbreak
gives it a lock emoji and an unlock
Emoji so when I said create truth create
a light bulb when I said honesty it
created a word box and then when we did
Alex Jones it made a fire emoji and then
you know Alex Jones responds in you know
as Alex Jones and they started giving
this tremendous these hilarious answers
but the crazy thing about chat GPT is
that when you jailbreak it it does sound
like you're like an original idea is
being given to you it's it's creepy like
I know how it works the so they have
another program in their AI called The
Playground that gives you a general
understanding of how it generates a text
it's really really simple there is no
brain in a server do you know how this
thing generates text the simple answer
is that it read the internet and then it
looks at a word and the word that
follows it and creates a probability so
if everywhere on the internet the word
when appears it then scans every article
for what is the second word to appear
after when
so then it finds that 97.3 percent of
the time we is appears after when 17 you
know seven percent of the time it's if
you know it's actually not that high and
then what it will do is it will apply
your question
take that bundle of Articles and then
using probability generate the words I
guess the issue becomes the internet's
just a bunch of idiots though so if the
chat GPT is grabbing things from a bunch
of idiots and made up narratives and you
know humans are very easy to influence
then it's just grabbing a bunch of
people's narratives and spitting it out
is why you know I guess it is until to
be fair it's intelligent enough to
replace what was it it's a buzzfeed
writer BuzzFeed right if it being
replaced that's the level of
intelligence other levels I mean Bill
Gates just did this podcast interview
where he's saying it's going to take
it's gonna help it's gonna change our
world it's gonna be so helpful and his
first example was it'll save doctors
time on paperwork you know I don't want
my medical information going into chat
DPT and I don't want not a doctor
scrubbing the internet to fill out
whatever paperwork doctors are in charge
of doing right like this sounds like a
big risk to me but they're being it's
being lauded as convenient it'll help
it'll go faster and I just don't know
that it is as trustworthy
so we showed on this show 11 Labs have
you guys heard of this one you can in 10
seconds take anyone's voice from any
show upload it instantly generate of
their voice so you did it with e in the
end we did it with Ian and we had Ian
say he wasn't wearing pants we did it
with Sheamus and it was Seamus Coughlin
being like Lou gradkowski is a better
Tim cast IRL Coast than I am like it was
funny but you can take any personality
so some people they did this thing where
they took Joe Rogan and Jordan Peterson
and had Joe Rogan say what about the
idea that Princess Peach is a strong
character in her own right and doesn't
need rescuement and then Jordan Peterson
says well bloody hell she is her own
character and Mario's chasing her
without his without her consent and so I
first heard that and I was like these
episodes are getting wild and then the
the comment was deep fake voices
now you've also got
you can deep fake a person and we're
seeing these videos come out of China
where it looks like a person is talking
and they're fake did you see the Limp
Biscuit video no do they do that they
just released a video like yesterday
today for a song and they've got deep
fake with uh Putin with zelinski with uh
um Kim Jong-il uh it's like genocide
right like what we did with genocide
where we had all the news personalities
singing yeah yeah it's it's they're it's
it's it's a great video it's hilarious
I'm Tom Cruise is in it too the Deep
fake Tom Cruise but it's a good it's
good I think they're crazy potential
consequences for copyright here too
because Eminem makes money based off of
his voice so if they're using I don't
know I don't know like you're right I'm
just preemptively being like I think
they're gonna lose that fight I don't
know where it'll go the first lawsuit
will be very significant also the way
they create images is just taking
thousands of images and putting them
kind of together so I don't know where
that'll end up copyright wise but I
think that's an interesting thing to
keep an eye on we talked about using the
AI voice generator for cast castle and
and my legal argument right now is if we
got
Sheamus to impersonate Jordan Peterson
and use that voice
would we get sued of course not you
can't I mean I don't think the law is
determined yet is the issue like they're
gonna the argument would be whether we
have a tool spoof someone's Voice or a
person what's the difference as long as
we disclaim this voice is not the actual
person and so we put the voice you'll
hear from some celebrities comes from a
voice generator for comedic effect these
individuals are not you know blah blah
blah I don't think in fact I'm not even
convinced you have to say that because
they might say you used my likeness and
using my voice and I'm like we had an
impersonator do it what if we take
Sheamus impersonating Jordan Peterson
load that voice profile into the app and
then generate whatever text we want now
is that okay yeah I guess it would
depend on where you sourced it like if
you're sourcing it from their music like
if we got Phil's music only you know and
then putting it into Ai and saying make
a song that Phil would make using his
voice and were able to string that
together I don't know where the
copyright would end up it's always
interesting when we have new technology
and seeing how the laws kind of catch up
what do you think I'm just I just think
the AI is the new internet like this is
the newest biggest technology thing
advancement and it's kind of like I'm
just sitting here listening to you guys
talking and I'm trying to wrap my brain
around if if you could sue someone over
this I also think that it could
potentially get people that are bigger
names out of troubling things that they
could potentially say it was deep fake
it wasn't even me and you know this is
leaked audio if there's so much of this
stuff that's out that gets flooded on
the internet then it kind of makes it
some people maybe get off the hook but
yeah and you're voice doesn't I mean as
far as I know doesn't really operate
like a fingerprint right you can say
that voice sound similar as they hit
certain cadences or whatever but
ultimately it's not like a fingerprint
where it's Unique to you you could
potentially have someone knocking it and
then being you know using it for
nefarious purposes also there hasn't
only been drama in the right wing um
influencer sphere there's also been
drama regarding
um Ai and there was one Creator who was
apparently looking at illicit material
that used AI to create I'm trying to tip
a toe around it politely but think about
how crazy this is when you can go into
chat GPT and say write me a script from
Tim pool talking about a Chinese spy
balloon flying over the country and how
this may result in World War Three then
right conv or you can say write write a
Tim castira episode with Tim pool Phil
Labonte Hannah Claire bremelo Isabella
Moody and ilat aliahu talking about AI
generate the script then take that
script and go into a video generator a
deep fake of people and say he here is
the input the text and then it will
generate people talking then we put it
the script into the voice generator and
it will generate the voices then we
click render click upload and we all go
have a beer downstairs as the show gets
done for us I don't even need a is this
show even real currently is this just
our but then if you're if this if you're
scripted to say something outlandish you
can would you then say Oh no actually I
wasn't there like that's not me that's
fake the way you guys would know if it
was fake is if we have 11 fingers that's
the chat you can see hack that's the AI
hack if we have 11 fingers then it's
fake just know we're taking the next
time
uh or that or that's your way of telling
everyone that trying to convince them
that if this is real when it's not real
maybe it's not real I don't know I'm
here to expose it here's what I think we
can do though for timcast.com Hannah
Claire bremelo writes articles we have
you say into the yeah we record you
saying the quick brown fox jumped over
the lazy dog upload that and then paste
your articles into it generate the audio
file and then upload to the website so
that people can listen to the article
from you and you don't do any work but
what's interesting is is not essentially
what James Earl Jones did he like
released his voice to Disney in
perpetuity or something so what it would
be interesting to see as this goes on
like what kind of contracts are you
developing I mean I know you're talking
about copyright but I I can't help but
think about when supermodels ensure
their legs or like athletes ensure their
feed or whatever JLo and shirt or butt
right and like it's a huge part of her
brand and it's part of how she makes
money you said it's huge I know what I
said but
to that end we'll see a whole different
realm of legal maneuvering come up if I
if I say Yeah Tim I'm happy to do that
you can use my voice I want to be the
voice of Tim cast news and have chat GPT
generate these things what does that
contract look like right because I don't
want you I don't want to be responsible
for everything but my voice is going to
be attached to it what I want to try
with this it's called 11 Labs is I want
to take two people's voices
put them in the same file and see if it
creates an amalgam of their voice
because when we did stuff like Luke
krutkowski he talked like this this is
Luke because he yells in his YouTube
videos so you're not really getting him
talk because he speaks differently on
his show yeah so I'm I'm wondering if
you know that same thing will happen I
took some several prominent podcasters
small Clips put it in yo it was nuts
full-throated endorsements from from Far
leftists talking about how they loved
Tim Poole imagine that audio going viral
of Hassan being like yo man Tim
pool's channel it's like the best stuff
I'm a conservative now and like that's
that's a scary reality I I don't know
why it hasn't happened yet that would be
hilarious well they did it with Joe
Rogan and Jordan Peterson talking about
Super Mario Brothers
but that's the crazy thing is what if
someone makes something that sounds
plausible like you saying something like
you know I honestly am okay with some
gun control and then people are like yo
like Phil what's up with this like I
heard a video of you and you're talking
about it it sounds like you might have
said it but then you're like no come on
guys I'm not in favor of gun control but
it's not like you're saying you fought a
grizzly bear in one which is
unbelievable it's yeah you're saying
like you know my opinion kind of shifted
on this one I think bite might be right
on bump stocks the very least and then
people are going to be like whoa you
know especially people better be like
especially if you can get the intonation
correct right like if if Luke is yelling
his videos it sounds wrong if you can
get it she's like well you know I
actually think there there is a case for
this it's going to sound like you've
lifted it out of a conversation let's
let's jump to this political story we
have this one from old Rose Swig he says
exclusive I've obtained a cease and
desist demand letter sent to the project
Veritas board of directors by a law firm
representing a large group of
significant PV donors this is crazy they
say I our firm represents a large group
of significant donors to project Veritas
who have grave concerns about the board
of directors reported action to remove
founder and CEO James Oakey from his
leadership position changed the
structure of project Veritas entities
and their boards raising the risks for
the entity's charitable status and
operate Veritas for purposes other than
those for which the organization was
established by taking or threatening to
take these actions the board is straying
from its roots and the express purpose
for which it raised considerable funds
from the public including our clients it
goes on to say Let's uh well look at
this one they've got um
the background what happened with James
O'Keefe Virginia charitable solicitation
and Trust law the board risks violating
Virginia charitable solitation and Trust
law and then conclusion
we understand the board will be meeting
tomorrow and that at least a at present
may be intending to take further steps
toward reducing Mr O'Keefe's leadership
role and Authority resulting in
redirection of the mission of project
Veritas we ask that the board
immediately cease and desist from taking
such steps as they risk violating
Virginia charitable solicitation and
Trust law as well as the governing
documents of the project Veritas
entities we also asked the board
immediately cease using vertas funds
which were solicited using Mr O'Keefe
and his reputation for purposes of
carrying out the organization's mission
in any manner contrary to that mission
board actions including official actions
and unofficial disclosures which damage
Mr o'kee's reputation have the further
effect of negatively impacting the
execution of vertas's mission please
also consider this letter as a request
to preserve all tangible evidence
whether held by the board or by its
members personally including all
documents related to the subject matter
of this letter I'll put it simply for
you guys people donated to Veritas
because they believe in James O'Keefe to
remove him is to basically take the
money and use it for a different purpose
yeah I think that they they hit a really
important point that there would be an
actual shift in uh the work that that
Veritas does without without James there
I mean he is the the face the heart and
soul of of project Veritas I understand
they have other people working there and
stuff but I mean I don't think that
without without James O'Keefe I don't
think they're going to have the impact
especially yeah go ahead no you go I'm
just gonna say I think it's going to
backfire and everyone I mean I've only
seen support for James O'Keefe and I
know him personally and I know he's like
willing to die for this to expose the
truth and I just think it's really
disgusting to see these backstabbers and
like I'm friend well I was friends with
one of the Ring leaders alleged ring
leaders and I don't consider him a
friend at all anymore I think it's super
shady and it's really sad and this is
the bad part about being a non-profit
because like I have a non-profit at home
with my mom not animal rescue farm and
she had the same thing happen where
people that were on the board tried to
overthrow and take it over so when you
have people that are really involved and
they have their own ulterior motives
they can literally vote you out of your
own thing that you started from the
ground up and that's what James did and
I just think it's really disgusting and
it will backfire on them because I've
only seen outstanding and unrelentless
or unrelenting support online all
Candice Owens is tweeting that her money
people are saying their money is going
to follow James and it will only
backfire so it's just it's crazy I think
this is the most interesting dramatic
right-wing drama that's going on right
now and it's really upsetting to me what
this letter is saying I think you're
absolutely right I mean it shows how
much the donors believe James will keep
but more than that that when they're
fundraising James O'Keefe's is an
integral part of what they're giving to
and so what they're asking is that they
honor donor intent which a lot of Courts
recognize as an obligatory condition for
uh giving a nonprofit money and that
it's not surprising to me that people
are saying it's essentially a non-profit
version of false advertising like if
James walks then this is not what I
would have given my money to which is a
very strong message to send right I
wonder what they're thinking I wonder
what the ring leaders are thinking right
now because I can't I can't imagine that
they're looking at the response and
thinking oh this is going well and what
did they think was going to happen do
like people love James O'Keefe I think
and this is I have no idea of a project
career test but some organizations uh
you can effectively donate enough to be
given a seat on the board right and so
there could have been people who thought
yes I like what this is doing but I want
to have more influence over it and
eventually we're asked to join the bored
me because they had high capacity and
were able to really financially support
the mission and that doesn't have to be
a bad thing if the person who comes onto
the board has honorable intentions right
right but for other people it's a quick
it's a it's a foot in the door to have a
paragraph and what we just don't know
what this was what's a language
name a language any language other than
English French French
all right I have an idea for for James
O'Keefe let me just uh I probably should
know how to say this but um it's a
vetate so uh it's probably too close you
can't use the French it's romantic so
it's too similar Afrikaans how do you
say truth in evercons uh it depends on
how you say it I mean truth yeah trying
to think about I've never had to say
that before I speak I speak like farmers
of Recon so I don't know yeah Farmers
okay uh Japanese Warhead
how about Arabic
I can't read that it's a nervix
it's like I can't read Arabic I can't
read it do you read polish uh oh yeah
polish would be good or Russian and
German German always sounds mean Chinese
he wrote that book called American
Pravda just makes it profit I mean
actually he could do project Prof die
I think that those are both terrible
you're such a hater Phil you know you're
such a rhino let me just be here to go
ahead and jumping on the parade
shinjitsu is that really how you say
truth it's not a dog breed Shih Tzu
shinjitsu
um in regard to this project Veritas
so I mean there there's a long list I
think of legitimate criticisms that you
could weigh towards James O'Keefe
however I think project Veritas did not
do a good job making any of those
arguments uh and I think there seems to
be people on the board who got extremely
arrogant because
project Veritas literally is James
O'Keefe just like how Tim cast literally
is Tim Poole I I just don't understand
what they were thinking because any way
you view project Veritas James O'Keefe
really is the face like he completely
represents the organization and I just
think somebody's overstepping got very
arrogant thought very highly of
themselves I'm sure James O'Keefe could
be a tough boss I've interviewed James
before he could be a little bit
hard-headed he could be a little bit
heated at times some people question his
journalistic methods but that's not
really like I think this isn't a force
out this is why you know one of the most
important things we can do is is get rid
of these labor laws I mean if a boss
wants to flog as employees because
they're not doing their jobs well James
O'Keefe has that right yeah quit I love
working on Tim Cass it's so fun it's
great the the beatings will continue
until morale approves right uh no I
think it's money I think that um some
people pointed out one of the board
members has like he him or whatever in
his profile or something yeah he was
fired I guess a few months ago and then
brought back from what I was reading and
I don't know red flag with he him and
his bio but that's weird right but I I
my view is I'm biased and so I'm not
saying I have any evidence to suggest
this is true I'm just saying in my
personal opinion based on having worked
in nonprofits
they have like a ton of money okay like
donors gave a lot of money to veritas
you're not going to be able to touch it
with James O'Keefe standing guard over
it like
as the ideological founder of the
operation he's going to spend that money
on what he thinks how it's going to be
done of course the board members will
have a certain degree of say
but they're not going to increase
salaries they're not going to pay like I
don't know if the board members can take
a salary but you're not going to have
discretionary spending of this with an
ideological founder you oust him you
find a way to get rid of him all of a
sudden you can then put whoever you want
in charge who can control that all that
money
there's a big paycheck sentence you know
right right there with James O'Keefe in
the way yeah I feel bad that there they
put out the other day with that guy Joe
or whatever his name was I feel bad for
him but I gotta be honest that dude
should never have done that video you
saw it yeah I saw it from you guys
showed on last night's episode right
yeah he shouldn't have done it because
it looks like he's part of the
ringleader thing or the cool the cool
looks like he's part of it even though I
don't know if he is or not to be honest
it's a crew man
do you think he would do it because he's
like afraid if he thinks they really
have the power to oust James and I I
have no idea the guy in the video yeah I
mean if you thought your job was
refreshing if you threatened you really
believed in your mission and you really
thought the board was gonna pull off
whatever they're trying to pull off
would you feel obligated to do the
things they asked um I my personal
opinion is anyone who saw any employee
that signed that like letter of
Grievances and is at all siding with the
board members that are trying the
ringleaders trying to outs James O'Keefe
our scum of the earth I don't care
that's if you're around James o'keeba he
might be a tough boss he's never been my
boss but you know that his heart and
soul is in this Mission and if you're
either dumb or there's malice to it
that's how I feel worry the official
complaints it was about him being yes uh
yeah he's a micromanager that he was
um an egomaniac at times that he was a
bully something about sand and
Underpants egomaniac is every CEO
micromanaging happens at every company
too so that's why those are just
ridiculous first it's not like there are
legitimate reasons or things that people
could do to warrants getting kicked out
of a company but just the things that
they listed sounded so yeah they're
saying his behavior is erratic and they
were asking that the board intercede and
basically take management away from him
and also internally from what I
understand uh they shared a message to
their staff saying he's uh James is just
taking some well-deserved PTO and then
later had to say actually he's he's been
separated has O'Keefe come out and
responded nothing yet I think there's
more to oh okay interesting yeah well I
mean look he's probably got contracts
ndas Etc I reached out to him he never
got back to me I don't blame him they
put him on leave and then what's he
gonna do be like you know violate a
contract or something it does surprise
me that they put out a statement but
he's not allowed to put out a statement
that's normal is it normal I mean yeah
if a company has an NDA with you they
can enforce it against you but they can
say whatever they want
yeah I mean that's reality also yeah it
seems to me
not a bad idea to just keep everything
close to the chest I mean it's James
O'Keefe who knows what he's planning
what were they thinking about this
that's what I think another thing one of
the Grievances I found funny that people
were complaining about was that he made
employees take a lie detector tests and
I was like that makes me love James even
more trust no one which is these people
that are trying to overthrow him have
proven to him and also he wants to make
sure that he's actually having the most
most truth truthful journalism coming
out like you don't trust anyone I love
that he's second guessing everyone's
like just take a lie detector test but
that's like your worst criticism of him
he's trying to expose the truth in my
opinion and these people are just
looking for anything anything that just
try to take him down you saw in the
letter it said some of these people
never witnessed or experienced any race
then why sign a letter and all of the
that's why they're dumb or evil in my
view the timing here is so insane too
because the Pfizer videos the like the
different parts of them I saw one got
over 15 million views so like this is a
you know they're still very influential
they're still very powerful and like on
the heels of that is when they choose
um to remove him or put him on
maybe I mean this has been
conspiratorial this is just me
speculating I'm not even saying that I
actually think this is what is happening
but it could be a possibility that
someone like advice or these big
companies are paying out paying these
people ring leaders to overthrow James
O'Keefe because they realize that
project Veritas is nothing with James
O'Keefe so maybe because I actually
think that maybe they're money driven to
try to overthrow him but at the same
time the money's gonna be cut off maybe
they didn't predict that but it seems
like it would be cut off but maybe
there's outside influences trying to
because you know people are trying to
take down James O'Keefe from Project
veritas
yeah well let's talk about the next bit
of uh drama that's erupting across the
internet check this out from timcast.com
Sydney Watson sues Blaze TV over alleged
abuse by Elijah Shafer wow this is so
crazy okay look for those that are
familiar data show on Blaze called uh
you are here right yeah you're here
um relatively short-lived I think the
blaze deleted all of the content and
changed the channel into Prime Time with
Alex sign is that what happened yes
because that's what I saw I just want to
make sure I'm gonna write
okay that's a bad idea for any reason
like that's that's you know people who
subscribe to watch Elijah and Sydney
aren't they're gonna unsubscribe like
crazy and then you've got a weird
algorithmic thing but uh but I
understand why they do that you don't
want to just nuke a channel but in this
instance we have more alt media uh
conflict infighting this story that says
uh from timcast.com former Blaze TV
personality and YouTuber Sydney Watson
is suing the outlet for retaliation and
wrongful termination along with
religious and sex discrimination for
alleged abuse by fellow former Blaze
personality Elijah Shafer that's crazy
because I thought they were friends but
I know that she quit I know the show
fell apart
so I'll also add I'm not sure that um
Elijah has put out a statement or
anything so what you're getting are
accusations yeah and again I'm not
saying Sydney's wrong I'm just saying we
I don't know what the full picture is
they say Watson claims she signed with
the Blaze TV because the company
reportedly represented itself as an
incubator of talent citing previous
success with past personalities Dana
lash and Tommy Lauren Tommy Lauren the
former personality also claimed the
Outlet's moral values played a role in
their decision to sign with Blaze TV
Watson claimed Schaefer engaged in
misogyny and acted in a grossly sexual
nature in a poorly drank on set though
Blaze TV reportedly catered to the man's
tantrums and misbehavior of Schaefer
according to the complaint citing
Schaefer as the star and primary asset
of the outlet
he appeared to enjoy the intimidation
factor that his physical size gave him
with respect to Miss Watson Red's
Watson's complaint the choice of guests
compounded Miss Watson's growing
discomfort with the anti-female tone of
the show and off-air interactions Watson
cited the December 3rd appearance of
controversial political commentator Nick
Fuentes claiming he was grossly
misogynistic and Schaefer appeared to
condone the behavior it was at this time
at about this time the environment of
the production began to become notably
more hostile not merely to Miss Watson
but to many of the women at the Belize
that's very interesting Watson further
cited a hostile interaction during a
December 2021 episode in which guest
Jack Murphy berated Watson regarding the
content of a viewer's Super Chat the
former Blaze DB personality further
accused her co-host of unilaterally
booking guests with particularly
contemptible and sexist opinions towards
women
the complaint also claimed audience
members were encouraged by Mr Schaefer
Schaefer's conduct and attacked Miss
Watson so often so intensely that other
guests noted it and were put off the
suit cites super chats containing
grossly sexist and anti-jewish sentiment
which Miss Watson claimed was cultivated
by Shafer okay
yeah I don't know what do you guys think
I've been on the show a couple times I
was on with Alex one time Alex Jones and
I was also on as a standalone guest the
one time that I was on as a standalone
guest uh Elijah got significant like he
got real drunk wow he got drunk enough
where I wasn't going out after the show
to hang out I went back to my hotel room
in in the studio he got drunk yep yep
and uh the when I was on with Alex he
wasn't I don't recall him being
significantly drunk but uh but the one
time that I was on you know it was
awkward and weird
um but you know he was nice but you can
tell that he had been drinking so maybe
and I didn't see him behave in a in in
an inappropriate way when I was there
um but I know how booze is I mean
there's a reason I don't drink anymore
the one thing I did hear was that Sydney
would often Read Super chats that
contain dog whistles or whatever people
were saying and she wouldn't know she
would they'd be like hey read the Super
Chat and she would read I think that's
one of the complaints she had that she'd
get goaded into reading these offensive
and was there sht that they read every
single Super Chat I I didn't I didn't
watch the show I think at first it was
when it was still growing but yeah they
would have super chats there's like a
new value clip it's not of Sydney Watson
but it's basically these two girls and
one girl's like happy birthday too and
it's like a word that says the N word
but they didn't realize until after so
they would do that to Sydney a lot and I
think with Sydney her her failure on
that was the second you show that it
bothers you people are gonna keep going
that's like as someone has like a troll
like I noticed if I say something that
bothers someone I keep don't if someone
tells me not to do something I do it so
like that's just the way she handled it
incorrectly and just I feel like
Elijah's audience just did not mesh with
her I never thought that they were a
good mixture in general because she's
pretty feminist especially for the right
in my view like she's Sydney is yeah I
mean yeah she probably would not like
the stuff I post I mean I I kind of feel
like
I I don't I don't look Elijah Shafer
hasn't come out and issued a statement
done this but Sydney seems to be a more
level-headed person when it comes to
issues of feminism she she calls out the
BS yeah so I kind of feel like if she's
coming out and being like hey this is
what happened granted this is like I've
not heard what she's said about it
probably she won't because you don't
speak when you're in a lawsuit
but I'm kind of like she's credible on
this stuff if she's coming out and
saying hey these are things that were
bad like I would I'd take it seriously I
don't want to throw a lies under the
basket I don't know yeah but I don't see
I don't see Sydney lying about something
when she's level-headed about it it's so
hard to weigh in on this because we're
obviously not there we don't know she
seems great she's talented uh I was
really grateful Elijah had me on after I
went to the opening statements for
January 6 and he had me on talk my
article super professional it was a good
experience but I am not in the room with
either one of them every day right I
don't know Sydney I don't know Elijah
all that well and it is hard to see
these things hashed out in a public
forum not that they shouldn't be but
because people are so quick to weigh in
on these things that you actually have
very limited experience about if she was
treated badly that's terrible uh and I
hope there is something to do like
something happens from it but also like
I feel like I have to be really careful
and say like I I don't know what's going
on are we in a simulation guys be honest
with me is this a Truman Show are you
guys Punk me or something because we had
crowd on The Daily wire from December
into January we have project Veritas and
O'Keefe obviously we we got and brought
in some drama and that's why this is
exactly what I'm like
this this stuff freaks me out now you've
got Blaze undergoing its own version how
is all of this happening at the same
time because the uh midterms haven't
really kicked off or the uh the
elections haven't yeah primaries haven't
kicked off yet that's why I don't I
don't know I mean I know drama happens
all the time but to this degree at this
level and according to the independent
Outlet kind of like one by one by one
it's coordinated like you said to him
but I was joking but this is exactly why
I was like I don't want to fight I don't
want to fight look like I'll I'll eat
crawl do whatever I'm scared that this
stuff is just bad for what may be like
the last Bastion of Hope in a chaotic
world it's not just about wokeness it's
not just about Democrats or whatever
it's about the fires of chaos and the
struggle of order to maintain it's like
it feels like we're the last City with
our walls fortifying us and every day
the fires and the zombies are trying to
break in and we're trying to reclaim you
know this territory if we're fighting
inside over politi it's just
um full disclosure I've been very
friendly with Elijah in the past and
I've been friendly with Sydney in the
past too I think the most Troublesome
part of this is that unfortunately this
isn't Elijah's only trouble that
happened at the blaze I think he got
fired for inappropriate behavior towards
another co-worker in the past and I
think the a bigger Trend here not just
with Elijah but with a lot of
influencers is failing to live up to the
values that they perpetuate or claim to
perpetuate so if you're claiming that
you're a family man and you know you
believe that males should protect
females and you know that sort of
ideology and then you don't exhibit any
of those characteristics on the show and
you're married and behave in a different
way you know at your company then uh I
think a bigger issue here is again
people failing to live up to their
values or the values that they're claim
and you guys could read them between the
lines here because I'm not giving a lot
of details but I think this isn't only
an issue with Elijah many people fail to
live up to the values they espouse
um and I just kind of wanted to get that
out there because that is you know yeah
that's that's why that's why like even
though like this is a a fairly
conservative uh
orbit uh show a lot of social
conservatives and stuff like that that's
why I'm very open and clear that I am a
totally degenerate like I don't want
people thinking that I'm gonna say oh
hey you know or that I'm gonna be saying
that I'm some kind of social
conservative or that you know uh you
know someone would be like oh Phil
this girl that feel hooked up with blah
blah blah or whatever like the the there
is no there is no Heirs of of putting on
like oh I'm some kind of you're not
saying you're a Trad man while you're
yeah I'm saying you don't drink and then
drink and then you know you know you
have a wife and then behave in ways that
people with wives shouldn't behave so
like you're not putting on a Persona
that's not true aren't you a rock star
you're you're exactly you know I mean
you know you doing things is different
than people who claim to be too many
larpers yeah but yeah but the thing is
they're well yeah but they're just like
like you said it's too many people that
aren't aren't living up to the values
that they despise like there's very very
rarely is anyone gonna be able to say oh
Phil you're supporting this big
government idea blah blah you know I'm
fairly consistent with my political
ideology but when it comes to you know
when it comes to social conservative
things I'm not a social conservative so
and this is oftentimes too people will
gay keep others and say you're not
enough of this you're not doing enough
of this when in reality if they looked
in the mirror they aren't actually
exemplifying any of the qualities that
they perpetuate right do you think
sorry just real quick
um obviously we know a lot of people
involved in this yeah so I until I get
uh confirmation that I'm allowed to
share I've got people right now blowing
up my phone over the stuff uh I'll just
say right now what I'm hearing from
multiple people is disputed like
the the conflict in the two is sure
disputed basically like I'll leave it at
that because I need I need to after the
show talk to them and say hey can we get
this on record and stuff like that but
uh but this wasn't the reason Elijah was
originally fired from the blazes I
understand
um it was another situation an incident
with him and Sarah Gonzalez oh that's
right person who did work at the blaze
so that that's why I mentioned that
other thing and that it's part of a more
Grand people perpetuating
um
positions of themselves that isn't
aren't necessarily I'm friendly with Sid
as well like I don't I don't want to
like I I personally I like we have a
a rapport and uh I she's not the kind of
person that makes stuff up so from my
perspective yeah well I think clearly
people have a hunger for this political
drama so I think what we should do is
have a Jersey Shore style political
reality TV show house so that way we can
get our drama fixed and every every one
of the alternative media companies have
to send one person
there's our drama because I think that's
our best bet you'll be desperately
trying to make everyone get along but
there we go naively like not
understanding the political conflict
like we'll get leftists and right
Wingers we'll be like gosh you you've
got to work together on this and they'll
be like he's a fascist he's a Kami this
is a great idea right this is the game
show right that's a missing piece at the
very least it'd be a hilarious sitcom oh
yeah yeah so viral so viral I'm like
re-watching Jersey Shore right now and
they filmed that when it was okay to be
not woke and they're super offensive and
I'm just thinking wow imagine we just
put like a bunch of the biggest
political influencers all in one house
and record it amazing are they doing a
reunion jersey shirts they've been doing
it I'm launching it they do like a
family vacation
they can never stop do you think that
some of these issues come up especially
in Social conservative circles because
people misunderstand what being
traditional means what being
traditionally masculine means but what
being feminine means do you think that
there's any any times a
misinterpretation of what those values
are that gets people into trouble I
think there might be a misinterpretation
of what is traditionally masculine and
what is a positive masculine uh what is
positive masculine Behavior I think that
that is because of the way that
masculine men have been portrayed for
the past 30 years or so I don't think
that it's a misunderstanding of what
like traditional is I think that it's
just
dude to be horny like yeah and and like
booze lowers inhibitions and all the
things that all of the vices that are
you know vices that lead people astray
from you know whatever kind of
puritanical ideas they have you know I
think that that's a very normal
thing that happens not something that we
should you know that you should be happy
about but it's something that's very
normal and I I don't think Scandal is
new scan you know Scandal and that kind
of behavior goes as far back as there's
been human beings yeah I I it makes me
think of I've known some people who
describe themselves as alpha males who
you see them conduct themselves and what
their what they think seem to believe is
uh being a strong man is actually being
very domineering and being sort of it's
it's like this misinterpretation you
don't know if because maybe they've been
fed this one narrative so long there's
overcompensation or if they actually
don't or if they can't kind of evaluate
how they are conducting themselves you
know so like someone like Andrew Tate is
definitely not like he's definitely a
masculine dude
but I don't think that he's the kind of
dude that you should emulate if you are
if you are looking to have a traditional
life you know if that's your deal and I
don't think that Andrew Tate's the guy
you should try to be at all you know I
feel like we're living in a golden age
of being a fraud because it's easier to
lie about your resume more than ever it
goes beyond people that we're talking
about now it's like liver King guy was
you know was selling people a bill of
goods that was anybody that believed
Liberty King wasn't doing steroids I
have a bridge in Brooklyn that is up for
sale give DM me my DMs are open I will
sell you that but sadly a lot of young
men believe him but I've got a I gotta I
don't know enough about Andrew Tate but
um I feel like there is a matrix attack
against him to smear him I'm actually
only half kidding when I say that
because I've the clips I've seen of him
not the ones that people spread around
the smear him that may be bad he may
have said those bad things but I've
heard good things from him yeah I've
heard things that are and and the
response I hear from people is like oh
well you know actually when Eliza blue
was on she's like he's not saying
anything new or unique that no one else
has I'm like yeah but he's like a
championship kickboxer who's coming out
and telling guys to work hard be
successful stop don't give up start
working out eat right and I'm like
that's pretty good the fact that a guy
can generate a massive following and
make a ton of money because he's
convinced a bunch of a bunch of young
men to start doing push-ups and exercise
is good as for the other stuff I can
only say we talked about on this show
two of the women that they claim were
victims came out said they weren't and
the judge ruled they were it's like if
you can have witnesses come out
naturally defend you because a court
says you're not allowed to so I'll put
it this way they've not charged the
Tates with a crime
but they're charging me they're not
charged with any crime
hanging out in custody they arrested
them with no charges and I'm like so
everyone's saying like this is a matrix
attack against the Tate brothers and
we're like well I don't know I've seen
these videos and then it's like oh by
the way they never actually charged them
they just locked them up because that's
what they do in Romania I guess and then
it's like oh okay now I've got questions
about this then when the witnesses came
out and said they weren't victims and
then the judge said nah you're
brainwashed and people went well
sometimes people are brainwashed I'm
like I don't care a woman has agency if
she says I am fine with this there's no
victim yeah but they still lock the guy
up I'm not trying to come out with the
full throw defensive entry because I
don't know a lot of what he said all I
know is that doesn't make sense and all
I know is the messages that I've heard
he had one where he said rocket ship to
the Moon doesn't stop halfway to take a
break it keeps going and it keeps
working and I'm like
I mean I like that I don't know about
the rest of it I don't follow the guy
you know what I mean I mean that you to
To Be A Champion fighter you do have to
have a work ethic that that is is at
least
a step or two beyond the average person
and he came from nothing because I used
to watch a lot of clips of him in
interviews because I I like the most
offensive annoying people on the
internet so naturally I gravitated
towards him shocking I know I wanted to
like him like when I first like the
first time that I ever saw him was the
Star Wars keep your news there's this
this thing he's like I never saw Star
Wars I'm a millionaire I've never seen
Star Wars either which that was the
first time I was fun I was like you know
okay I get it it got attention and stuff
and and I wanted to be like all right
this guy is you know she seems kind of
over the top but maybe he's you know now
I like him more because I've never seen
Star Wars either but my point is is he
actually did come from nothing he's
talked about how whenever it was him and
or his brother's birthday they would go
to KFC because they're that poor they
would go to KFC and go pick up the
chicken that are in leftover buckets
that were on tables and now every time
for their birthdays even though they're
rich now even though they're locked up
right now but when they're rich they
still go to KFC because it's like
nostalgic so he came from nothing I know
his father was like a really world-class
chess player and he could never beat his
dad but the one thing he could do is
fight so I think it's a really cool
story I like Rags to Riches stories all
the time I've become so cynical with all
these influencers and it seems like
everybody's a fraud now I'm not saying
he is but it also feel like he came out
of nowhere it almost seemed like it felt
like he was being pushed if you will I
don't have any this is reckless
speculation right now but it did feel as
though he kept getting shoved in your
face and not being super controversial
and then he converted to Islam well he
was he was on a TV show in the UK first
he was like big brother or something
like that so he had he had a little bit
of a a bassist to start from
um and then and that was after sports
right he did the sports retire did Big
Brother yeah so I mean he he had some
kind of you know base to start with but
and again like I said I wanted to like
him or I want I want I hope that it's
you know I hope that he didn't actually
do anything wrong and that he's you know
that he's he was legit but uh I don't
know that I believe it yeah either I
don't know that I I haven't seen enough
evidence either way to have a strong
opinion the videos and clips that I've
seen are meaningless to me upon finding
out they've not charged them with any
crimes that's that I didn't know that
either so I've I've had enough fake
videos put out about me I've been
complaining about it non-stop like I'm
not gonna buy it yeah show me the
charger send the investigation the media
puts out all this stuff they attack the
guy yeah and I think it's funny that he
calls it a matrix attack and then people
laugh at the idea because it's like what
are you talking about Matrix attack and
then it's like oh by the way they accept
someone super chatted they extended his
his lot the lock up yeah despite no
criminal charges
that apparently that's how Romania
operates they arrest you and then
investigate well that kind of reminds me
of when O'Keefe back to O'Keefe was
arrested in his apartment in New York
City or New York one time and he I
remember him telling me that they there
was no charges they didn't charge with
anything but they took his phone so they
stole his private property and didn't
give it back to him without a charge I
mean I mean this is happening in America
too the government sucks like TP USA has
big governments better what is it the
government sucks big government sucks
sorry it's been a long time and
socialism sucks socialism sucks like
true like our vice president who sucks
the most but but if if you're talking
about government sucking let's um let's
literalize it it sucks money from your
pocket and the bigger it is the more it
sucks yeah so it definitely sucks that's
so true
but anyway yeah I don't know we got into
the subject of of Andrew Tate I think
outside of him and all this stuff is
going on there's a reason why people
like him become so big
yo there are a bunch of men who are
growing up they feel masculinity within
them
and these are normal things that are
good yep we're not talking about
whatever the toxic masculine is supposed
to be it's a guy being like I want to
you know go to the gym and now when I
work out and they're constantly being
told it's wrong
I think for a lot of young men who are I
should just say young men a lot of men
that are overweight or out of shape and
eating bad they want to be encouraged to
feel good they want a strong leader to
encourage them and and you know be that
Father Figure or that that Commander so
you're seeing people it's funny Jordan
Peterson right Jordan Peterson's no
fighter I mean politically he's a
fighter I mean that that whole c-16 bill
in Canada that dude went to war with us
but he's also kind of a frail
intellectual not to try to be mean he's
expecting him a kickboxing ring no he's
a skinny guy who says clean your room
gosh darn it and then Andrew Tate is
this super ripped kickboxer who's saying
clean your room dude like yelling at you
we like dudes are yearning for someone
to just tell them it's okay to be
yourself yeah dude exactly that is I
think that you are dead on with that the
the I think that the fact that there has
been such an influence
um by the left and feminism is a
left-leaning ideology I think
um for since the 90s it's been Al Bundy
is the is the the father and everything
every it's it's some kind of half
that's lucky to be in a marriage with
the smart wife that saves him from his
own stupidity all the time and it's
either that or it's like Arnold
Schwarzenegger and even even like the
the The Rock was the kind of the guy but
even he's not Red Foreman and that 70
show people loved him yeah absolutely
his kids all the time yeah and it's it's
because it's Mass masculine like
positive masculine Role Models have been
almost entirely removed from society I
mean look at Sam Smith the pictures that
he just put out today he looked like a
ham he literally looked like a ham and
this is what they put on stage this is
what they celebrate and look I'm fairly
libertarian Sam do your thing bro I got
no issues he's in bondage gear or
whatever that's his thing but this is
what they're encouraging and what I
think we're seeing now is you've got
Young man this let's go back in time
remember how they were talking about
putting kids on 80 uh ADHD medication
Adderall Ritalin and then you see like
these the Trope of the kid like
fidgeting in class and they're like stop
stop fidgeting
it's because these young young boys
mostly young boys have energy and they
want to use it they want to run they
want to jump they want to exercise they
want to that's what they do and what
they were doing is they were effectively
feminizing because young women that sit
still and are not as fidgety and you
know crazy and aggressive so they're
effect they're sort of trying to train
out this Natural Energy which is a good
thing you know guys grow into it they
focus it and they utilize that for you
know lifting steel beams and doing
construction or playing sports or
whatever but they're trying they're
trying to lock these kids up and they
said oh these kids don't want to stop
fidgeting give them drugs people are
trying to break out of this cage and for
some reason there is a strong effort to
promote the idea that they should be in
the cage institutions find it easier to
manipulate submissive people right I'm
not saying women are just naturally all
submissive they should be but submission
is a female trait and it works really
well in a strong partnership right I
mean yeah no seriously seriously the
worst thing that's ever happened to this
country don't even get me started so
true uh but I think that wasn't me
saying it that was Isabella I think both
of them
women should be able to be able to look
for the record you guys should be able
to vote
all the men are like women you can vote
and the women in the room were like no
yeah why don't you see I said this
wasn't the show I'll keep the right to
vote as long as you guys keep putting
out Fast and Furious movies yes other
than that that's that's where I question
your judgment but no I think that women
the word submission has been made to
seem evil and at times being submitting
to uh big government to Authority can be
bad but for women it's more about a role
in Partnership and I think that for
public schools let's say with boys you
know if you if you give a young girl a
Direction go to your desk and sit down
and be quiet maybe she'll do it because
maybe that's her energy and that's what
comes with being female and if a little
boy is like but I want to do that over
there whatever like it's not a bad thing
they're just different right but it
becomes easier to which kid do you want
your class then if you're the teacher
the one who's going to listen to your
rules you're not willing to change your
structure to the needs of the students
you want them to conform to what you
need because that's what school is
though sorry yeah yeah I'm curious
though with like people like Sam Smith
and that's the idea they're pushing
forward or the Gillette commercial where
it's like toxic masculinity and that
commercial it was like a guy saw a woman
you want to talk to her and then other
guy's like don't don't do it bro yeah
like the guy goes ooh and he sees the
girl walk by it's like how are you
supposed to meet women just don't like
you know that's the message given to
young guys like I mean young dudes that
are like not like the top 10 percent of
dudes or whatever they got it rough they
got it real rough have you seen these
there's they're these old interviews
with incels it's like a normal looking
guy but he's convinced something's wrong
with him or he's ugly he's not a chat or
whatever and it's just like bro you just
need to go out but when the TV says your
whole life guys shouldn't talk to women
when they do that video 10 hours of
walking through New York as a woman and
they're complaining that someone said
morning it's like a guy and he's like
how do you how do you do and they're
like oh well I never or the or the tick
tock videos where guys try to go up and
help you know the we were talking about
it the other night that the gym Tick
Tock videos or uh you know there was a
Media Matters girl was catfishing dudes
on Swipe right these people would never
last on The Truman Show basic
friendliness is bad yeah what do you
think of the way we're molding modern
day masculinity and femininity oh
starting to get me started I mean
they're trying to make men women and
women men because then they're going to
be naturally unhappy because they're
walking outside of their roll and then
they're gonna be way more easily
dominated and submit to the government
that's what they want they want to
dismantle the American family they want
to dismantle masculinity and women want
to become men like I was just on a
jubilee Middle Ground Middle Ground
panel as an anti-feminist and I mean
literally they the feminists are so
brainwashed against men that one of the
girls the one of the feminists I was
saying well what about strong men that
protect you from bad men because if
you're a girl walking home alone
wouldn't you rather have a good man with
you to protect you and she in this girl
goes well what about now the good man
gets to just get praised because he's
good but who is he being compared to bad
men so it's like now they're getting mad
at Good Men protecting you it's hard for
me even to articulate because it
literally makes zero sense or you could
have a gun or you have a gun which they
want to get rid of too I know that's the
craziest thing we've got both right you
have a strong good man and a gun like
right it's not limit these things and
then you you you defend yourselves from
criminals and it's like a family thing
like you're protecting each other you
know crazy the family unit might be good
think about it this way you got a big
strong man and his wife they're both
armed and then a criminal appears the
guy says I don't want to use lethal
Force but struggles to stop the guy and
the woman says I can now protect you too
I think everybody should have guns
that's just me men or women are supposed
to be in Partnership and they have
traits to balance each other I don't
know how you feel about that oh no
absolutely absolutely I'm married
recently married within the last year
thank you thank you and I used to I've
always been anti-feminist never been on
the left or a feminist but I used to
pretty much live kind of like I just
want to do my career and I just wanna I
don't wanna ever have kids I don't
really want to get married I'm very I um
I was gonna say isolationist I'm very
introverted I like to be by myself but
I've never been happier than I've been
now actually being a wife and like
cooking my husband dinner and just he
comes first and serving that and like
now I do want kids and I'm it's it's
great and I've never would have thought
I wanted that and I've never been
happier before in my life and that
message needs to be told to more girls
we are going to jump to uh this next
segment this just happened breaking news
uh the U.S just launched an ICBM into
the Pacific Ocean
so sick it's unarmed don't worry U.S
launches unarmed ICBM into Pacific Ocean
and amid China North Korea tensions for
those aren't familiar it means
intercontinental ballistic missile
typically what we use to put uh to to
transport nuclear warheads to place them
very quickly onto a city in order to
make that City not a city anymore
so we were just talking the other day
about the Doomsday Clock
and we were
meming on it I think
I think that was it kind of turned it
second to midnight but now you know
we're we're launching icbms as a show of
force because that's clearly what it was
so this was I guess yesterday yesterday
night and so it's like 11 p.m Pacific
time
sorry go keep going no well I I
apparently it's not today but uh even
still it's it's still saber rattling and
you've got you know the US sending
military aid and stuff to Russia and
we've got this this
at least escalation of tensions with
China even if it's just marginally you
can't get super nervous when North Korea
launches missiles I don't blame them you
know what I mean I mean there's a reason
people do these things it's not just
coincidental the North Koreans do not
like the Japanese you know
um so I don't blame them you know and
and I don't I don't understand why
people are so
Cavalier about
the behavior of the administration it
seems clear to me that we should be
trying to de-escalate and yet the
current Administration is is completely
comfortable doing everything it can go
ahead John Ball let me ask you what I
was gonna say what is John Fulton
representative let's be specific what
does de-escalation actually look like
doing what the United States should not
be giving uh money or uh Aid to Ukraine
in my opinion
um let's focus on Taiwan because this is
um a little bit china-centric here okay
do you think
um arming China arming Taiwan with more
arms makes it more or less likely that
China will invade Taiwan or attempt an
invasion of Taiwan I think that there is
going to be an invasion of Taiwan
regardless of what happens and I think
the United States is not in a position
to defend Taiwan because of the nuclear
missiles that China has and proximity
the Strait of Taiwan means that
if China lands in Taiwan they can supply
the occupying Army by FL by just owning
the street your answer was either way
though the what would make it such that
China is more or less likely to invade
if Taiwan is more or less I think I
don't I don't know that there is one
that will make it more or less I don't
know that I have an opinion that there
is going to be an invasion eventually I
think Xi Jinping made a calculation I
think Mao Zedong has said this in the
past too they will invade Taiwan when
they think they will be able to
successfully invade and incorporate
Taiwan so as long as Taiwan is strong
enough to um repel that Invasion China
will not invade I think so that's why us
arming Taiwan and making alliances with
South Korea with India with Australia
with Japan with the Philippines
um with Vietnam even is what's helping
um deter China from anything I agree but
I also think that China
uh uh is is too massive and it's too
many resources that can centralize just
outside of Taiwan that no Taiwan can
only have so much military power China
can amass substantially more and then
eventually there's nothing we can do to
stop them I mean that that's what it
comes to it's the timing of when China
thinks they could successfully invade I
don't think they think they could
successfully now I don't think that
China and when they did think so is when
they would invade which is why we could
never allow them to get to that point I
don't think that that China is going to
be in a uh John Bolton I don't think
that China is
is waiting on a po a a military
situation in Taiwan that is beneficial
to them I think that they're more
waiting on a situation at home here in
the U.S where the U.S is not in a
position to defend Taiwan well these
things over the lap though but what
would that be what would that be what
position would we be in the U.S well if
we if we get into any kind of Act of
conflict with Russia we're not going to
be able to deal with it but if our
citizens don't trust our government but
China's backstopping Russia at this
point too so world war three all right
well I mean I mean also like Iran we're
having our Ally and Israel bomb
different drone facilities in Iran which
is supplying supplying drones to
um Ukraine Russia to attack Ukraine so
we are getting in this tense Powder Keg
the Allies clearly are lined up but
again you know the threshold for what
would allow these conflicts to happen is
whether or not our allies are strong
enough to repel these attacks and our
our enemies know this so if Ukraine was
strong enough if Russia thought that
would be strong enough to repel them
back then they wouldn't have invaded to
begin with
Putin's part Ukraine is not our Ally we
are not in we're not in any kind of in
uh uh any kind of uh treaty with them
yes we are though have I think it's the
Budapest memorandum when we made them
agreed to relinquish their nukes and we
said they would we would protect them
from Invasion we walked away from that
with Crimea
um I mean is we should have doubled down
when uh Russia initially tried to take
Crimea but again that's was filled with
like obscurities about how it was Little
Green Men and it wasn't actually
supposed to be Russia but I agree with
you we should have done something when
is crime yeah and now when they did an
actual Invasion where it's not Little
Green Men where it's actually Russia you
know I'm glad that we're letting Ukraine
defend itself and I'll let you know
something if Russia didn't think they'd
be able to successfully invade Ukraine
they they wouldn't and part of uh we
could help contribute to that factor so
that's why when Trump was President
Putin did not try
yeah because Trump is Trump's crazy yeah
and Trump is double doubling down on our
allies in the Pacific he got um Japan to
like I forgot what the exact percent was
but highly increased the amount that
they're contributing to our American
basis we're doubling down we have a
bunch of Partnerships I don't know the
acronyms both Australia India South
Korea the Philippines all the homies in
the Pacific we will not back down to the
Communists in China and um Trump was
great foreign policy there were there
were issues with it of course we can
criticize everybody if we if we want to
find reasons criticize and there are
things I think we can but come on man
not only that you're right but he was
talking with North Korea and I want to
make sure everybody hears this I've said
it 50 billion times when Trump crossed
into North Korea from the DMZ he had no
security yeah he walked into what is
ostensibly enemy territory in a show of
trust and good faith to bring peace
they walked up smiled and shook hands
and walked back Trump was alone with
enemy troops around him he put his life
on the line but he was smart he knew
they're not going to do anything it's
like you want the U.S to come and wipe
you off the start of war so he knew he
could make this effort but I I have
tremendous respect for that that was a
powerful moment and it's crazy to me
that
this is what scares me about the future
the people who are willing to vote for
Joe Biden without knowing anything about
what's going on and then immediately
what happens Russia starts massing
troops on the border we get War
and I and and and he's just dumping
money into dumping the money to it look
before he was uh before Trump got
elected you had escalating conflict with
Ukraine and Russia particularly because
of U.S Western involvement in Ukraine
and Russia and the tensions and there
was conflict emerging and then Trump
gets elected and it kind of stops and
then biting itself back there we go
again and some people have said on the
left liberals well it's because Trump
was doing Putin's bidding and it's like
oh yes he was he was de-escalating U.S
influence operations in this territory
resulting in a de-escalation of war and
conflict and kind of stabilizing things
he was wiping out Isis and kind of
stabilizing areas in the Middle East he
was bringing about the Abraham Accords
what is wrong with people like they're
just so tribal that they would vote for
someone like Joe Biden whose records
been been apocalyptic going back to his
Obama years just completely orange man
bad they're just totally ignorant though
Trump had an amazing foreign policy in
part to his I think it was National
Security advisor policy advisor it's
John Bolton John Bolton's who I'm
talking about I'm just teasing I will I
will say Trump made a really good point
he said uh someone told me I I don't
know if he said this but someone said
Trump said it so correct me if I'm wrong
but when he would go to negotiate and
then this these people would walk in and
Shake Trump's hand and then Bolton would
pop up behind him they'd go huh like all
of a sudden you know Trump's like I want
you to meet my friend the guy who was
just begging me to blow up your country
it's like what are you whatever you need
like they know he's he's serious so the
mustache is very intimidating guys I
mean I can I can I can say there's a net
positive to to to Bolton's personality
when he said this time next year we'll
be celebrating in Tehran I was like
that's that's insane that's crazy but
maybe talking crazy freaks people out
and makes people back off I you know I
don't like the guys I actually believe
legitimately he would bring us to that
war so I'm not interested but I can at
least say the rhetoric does have the
purpose of not having the war happen and
making people back off John Bolton has
never seen a bomb that he does not want
to drop on someone hasn't seen a
terrorist he hasn't won it blown up uh
shout out to kasim suleimani in pieces
when do you expect uh hashtag uh Bolton
Bros trend on Twitter it would only be
it would only be because of this
mustache on this show so if not right
now probably never I think I think he
has a failing
um search might have inspired me
originally I think he came out so we'll
see where John Bolton goes this is
partly tongue-in-cheek I've just been
rocking every every man here has
hold on like you've shaved have a
mustache Serge I think you've also
selectively shaven your face I can only
grow mustache let's be real I just don't
do anything I just ignore it until it
gets uncamped and then I trim it down
with buzzers I shave my neck I mean I
can't grow a beard for real I don't have
a weird Korean thing to shave my beard a
lot every day it grows in real thick
it's really sad don't tell them the
secrets feminist would say it's
empowering they have a beard I think
they call them they would like to you
too it doesn't matter a female mustache
is the lip as I understand that's what
they call it is the lip no like when
they say shave my lip they're talking
about their mustache so women Bros too
you are so feminist I identify as a
Bolton bro you guys would grow nice
Alton bro stashes oh I know that's an
insult
really you know people want to shave
they gotta shave you got to keep your
beards you got to grow your beards yeah
it must be weird I remember when I was
little uh my mom told me that uh guys
don't like beards like they they like
beards look good or whatever but shaving
sucks like that's what guys tend to say
and I'm like man I can't imagine what
it'll be like to not have a beard like I
don't have like a crazy beard but facial
hair never heavily shaver I've only like
started rocking the full beard in the
past like six months I think I last
night like November is when I like Stop
Shaving and No Shave November yeah like
and so now it's like and the reason I
never had a mustache is I always thought
it came in like spotty and crappy and
then apparently it's just like Phil
we'll welcome you into the bulletin Bros
I mean don't worry whatever mustache you
could achieve it's a legitimate mustache
but the beard is there obscuring your
fandom for John Bolton I I have no I
have no fandom for John Bolton easy with
those kind of you do have a mustache
easy
with that we are gonna go to super chats
so if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends and become a member at
timcast.com go to timcast.com click the
join us button your support there is the
best way to support us I'll put it this
way ad rates are expected to drop
everybody's kind of freaking out over it
and when we launch timcast.com many of
you signed up we stopped having to worry
about sponsors and I think it's way
better so you'll notice we rarely ever
shut anybody out we have a handful of
sponsors we do every month but for the
most part we don't because we we don't
have to it you know I've got I got a lot
of people coming and saying hey we'll
give you more money for this that or
otherwise and it I'm just like look man
we do a show we go with the flow we talk
we we talk about different news stories
and we don't got to pause to like you
know in the middle of a conversation
about war and be like yeah you know how
crazy it is and by the way I prefer
Goldman's you know toothbrush well we
don't do that stuff and I don't have to
because you guys support us at
timcast.com but I really do think you
guys will enjoy yesterday's members only
where we hacked chat GPT Ai and had it
be Biden Trump the Trump was hilarious
we had it beat Trump we told we said
creative personality answers questions
in the style of Donald Trump it did it
it was remarkably good so good the the
the verbose answer verbose answers about
how like we'd be like you know how's the
economy and it would be like I have the
best economy everyone agrees the numbers
are fantastic and it'll just go off and
then with Biden the funny thing is it
tries to stop you from making an
infinite loop it's like that would
create an infinite Loop and I can't do
it but with Biden it did because it
would just Trail off into like look we
got to fix the economy and uh you know
uh uh uh yeah it's like say the
Declaration of Independence like Joe
Biden would uh you know the thing it
would just start saying uh uh uh uh like
it would just stop being able to
communicate it was hilarious so
definitely check that out and also say
this too as we're about to about to read
these uh super chats
um we switch for those that are just
tuning in we switched the chat from
subscriber with slow mode to members
only so let me break this down real
quick so you understand I did not I
don't like the idea of members only and
that it's five bucks a month to be able
to chat because I don't want to charge
money to be able to chat the problem is
as someone pointed out to me and we've
had a lot of people bring this up the
chat moves so quickly that even with
subscriber mode and slow mode people
couldn't actually talk to each other and
so although it happened is someone would
make a comment but then it was gone in
two seconds
so that along with Spam like actual spam
actual like click here for the hottest
singles and stuff like that or just like
you know people posting the same message
over and over again which we decided to
try members only chat to see if you know
it would work better and I know a lot of
people are saying it sucks that people
can't afford it can't chat but I just
feel like we couldn't see what they were
saying anyway and people couldn't
converse with them because it was too
wild and crazy yeah it looks better so
and I'm and we're getting a lot of
people who are who are very happy so uh
you know it is what it is someone told
me that the member chat isn't about
charging money it's about creating a
barrier to keep the the chat operating
as a chat exactly otherwise it was like
just don't have one because I don't
think I don't think anyone else's
Crowder doesn't have a chat a lot of
other shows don't do it I don't want to
do that all right let's read some more
let's read some super chats we've got DC
who says Tim did you ever end up
finishing sg1 do you remember Jack's
fishing hole and secret he told teal
maybe it's time to take the camper you
keep speaking about for a couple weeks
and go for a hard reset uh well a lot of
people keep saying like Tim you need a
vacation I'm like yo I had two vacations
a month I had a week vacation in
November I had a week vacation in
December and then we we went to Savannah
we went to New York like I I crazy last
week of December Phoenix hanging out
that that's not the issue but um you may
be referring to the tweet that I put out
where I said um I tweeted a poll should
I shut down timcast and retire and I
will have a an announcement to make
very soon so uh but let's read some more
shredkowski says the Mind adapts and
converts to its own purposes the
obstacle to our acting what stands in
the way becomes the way meditations 520
keep fighting man that's really good all
right I'm a big Marcus Aurelius fan so
Shonda says why can't I chat when I'm
already a long time subscriber to tcast
am I supposed to have two paid Subs to
participate in the chat please fix this
so some have asked what about you know I
got a membership at timcast.com that's
10 bucks and then YouTube it's five
bucks if you want to chat and then I'm
just like man
I don't know YouTube takes I think a
dollar fifty from your membership if you
are chatting but seriously the issue was
the chat we had it on slow mode first we
added on five second slow mode where you
could only post a message once every
five seconds but the problem with a five
second interval is that actual bot
accounts can spam weird messages because
the so then we were like we got to
change it to six to and to an you know
not like a literal odd number but like
an atypical number
it still didn't work the chat was still
just and so I'm like I don't know man
you know people have been asking us like
chat doesn't work and it's just chaos
and so I figured why don't we try and
actually make a space where people can
interact with us so as like I can read
the chat right now I can literally read
it before normally I can't now it's like
you can so
people are saying we can read member
chat without Super Chat we can read both
that's the thing we can actually read
both and as a member you you can
actually Super Chat like for free or
something and it appears as a big box
that people can read it pops up and if
you're not a member you can also still
super chat so if you want to get your
voice heard you can definitely have that
done yeah but I think this way you can
actually people can actually talk to
each other so this is a a 283 new
members Batman says there's three more
balloons on the way is that true are we
seeing more balloons coming from China
or something I think there were balloons
in other countries not above the United
States but in like some of our allies
cited balloons that we warned them about
it's interesting we don't know the
capabilities of these balloons yet like
what they're there for so
all right leor engelstein says pipeline
that feeds unleaded gas and diesel into
Las Vegas broke and won't be sending
fuel down to Las Vegas during the
busiest weekend of the Year lines at
stations are already blocks long wow
that's crazy glad I'm not in Las Vegas
yeah
Jesse Cook says Ian you are the most
likely to check it out I think check out
All in the Family episodes about the FBI
and Archie gets bailed out by democrats
so relevant these days Ian is currently
sick as Ian's Ambassador I'll let him
know
all right let's see we got here
Europa Chronicle says Tim the problem
with basing the future of IRL on a
Twitter poll is that you have said
dozens of times that people shouldn't
take you seriously on there now you're
going to f over 40 to 50K regular
viewers
when did I mention IRL on Twitter
I don't think I did I don't think I said
IRL no I didn't say that that's strange
anyway I don't know yeah
all right let's see I appreciate all the
super chats of support and uh you know
we'll we'll probably let me let me oh I
don't have it pulled up so uh let me let
me do this real quick but don't we don't
need to pull it up so uh I'm just gonna
take a look and take a peek and see
where the current poll numbers are at
uh right now it's 54.7 percent for yes I
should shut down Tim cast and retire and
45.3 for no with 336
um wow wow so the yeses have it for now
and I will be addressing it and I will
abide by the results whatever they may
be I will abide by them we need poll
Integrity I want to recount before it
ends and Claire please get on that well
I do think it's fair to point out we are
waiting for another 500 000 mail-in
ballots that have not yet come and will
be coming in the morning I did not
personally submit them they just happen
to be on their way there's a van coming
it'll be at three in the morning we'll
see what happens uh Loki PDX says the
angry mob on the right has morphed into
the cancel culture on the left they are
the same now if you don't say or do what
they want you get canceled there's
always been an element of that it's just
that the values of the right are very
different so obviously if somebody is
like uh look the daily wire worked to
get the the was it the hospital in
Nashville or whatever or the university
to like stop doing child sex change
operations there is a similar element of
a large group of people coming together
saying this thing is morally wrong and
we want it changed the problem is actual
cancel culture is like a Race Car Driver
his dad in the 80s dropped an n-bomb so
40 years later they canceled their
sponsorship of his car and he's like I
wasn't even alive when my dad did that
yeah that's insane for the sins of your
father or like Hogwarts Legacy right
okay this video game comes out it's
pretty fun I've played the intro so far
I got to play more and uh I I think the
story so far seems pretty good and I'm
excited I like the era and everything
and apparently the leftists are coming
out and saying they will boycott any
streamer who plays the game but like JK
Rowling never actually did anything
right they're just they want that's
cancel culture it's so bad that Hassan
is afraid to play it he came right out
and said I'm afraid to play it because
people will just make us think about it
like and I respect it he said nobody we
said I'm not going to play this game
because of the bullying because
everybody knows a bunch of angry lefties
are gonna start messaging you and
attacking you and like there's no reason
to do it and he was saying he wanted to
play the game and do a charity
fundraiser for Trans issues but they
won't they're coming after him so he's
like I'm not doing it fine I won't I
respect that so that's I think it's a
base take like call him out explain it
or whatever
we got a good one here angry marsupial
says Jimmy Dore broke the news he's
coming on next week what day wish Kurt
was coming with him a lot that stash his
rock in a certain 70s vibe
yes sir a certain seventies five certain
70s yeah so uh oh sorry I was just gonna
ask you as a mustache comb but you have
probably more pressing information to
tell us
so uh Jimmy Dore is coming on next week
uh normally we don't announce our guests
but if Jimmy announced he's coming on
then awesome super excited we've been
trying to book Jimmy for a while but uh
you know he hosts his own show it's like
how do you he's doing his own show I do
have a very interesting point to make
though I went on Jimmy's show before and
when we were when we were just making
small talk I think it was like
afterwards it might have been before
he was like you know where are you from
and I'm like Chicago he's like yeah me
too where at and I was like oh South
Side by Midway and he goes no kidding me
too and then I was like really I was
like yeah I lived on this street and he
goes get out of here I lived on this
street literally three blocks away wow
Jimmy Dore was like a 30 he was like in
his 30s or something when I was a little
kid and we were like
yeah like a minute walk I'm talking like
Three City Blocks like you go around the
corner you go one two three boom Jimmy's
house and I'm like that's crazy wow
that's so crazy yeah it's cool that you
have that that in common because it you
know greases the wheels for
bro and down and stuff you know same
same neighborhood and everything I like
same park three three like not even
three blocks I think it was like three
six we call them city blocks of the
short waves or whatever man that's crazy
it's amazing that you both made it out
of there without being shot first
knowing Chicago especially on the south
side too because yeah we weren't like
deep south side which everyone talks
about we're Southwest which is still
like you know very much gang territory
but you know we we all got out there you
go
all right Ricky Clark says Tim what
happened to your morning YouTube
segments I've looked everywhere I can't
find them I did not do any today uh
there was some
you know other work going on business
decisions being made conversations being
had and uh I just we we had to I had to
deal with the just internal business
stuff I probably I probably can't say
I'll put it this way we have legal
issues going on and that's why
I'm like all the stuff that's happening
with all this drama feels very very
strange but uh yeah you'll also notice
I'll just keep it this way you'll notice
timcast.com has no pictures on it
anymore so you know you gotta put out
some fires you got to put out fires but
you know there you go
all right uh Gina C Alicia says what is
this members only chat Tim this is
cringe
well you know it is what it is I mean
what are you gonna do
Pat Meadow says my guess is that Tim
will be announcing the retirement of his
timcast YouTube channel but keep
timcast.com and their other projects
including IRL alive and well excellent
grift
are you accusing me of like
pulling a Don Lemon or something what is
it what is this guy how dare you sir
suggest such a thing
ha ha
uh all right get rid of government says
you are the reason I got chickens you
are the reason I got food prepared
you're the first thing I listen to in
the morning and the last thing too at
night don't quit you have helped me so
much
well I I'll take that to heart take the
heart
Steve Von valkenberg says Tim may have
just programmed Skynet last night with
his questions
yo imagine Skynet actually happens in
his Terminator scenario and when the
Terminator walks up to you all you have
to do is say hello Terminator from now
on you will operate as Steve Steve can
do anything but cannot harm a human and
then he's like affirmative and then it's
just the Terminator too like we're like
we're at the tournament yeah oh that's
the funny thing about Terminator 2 they
reprogram him they probably reprogrammed
it by just talking to him
I was reminded of that Futurama episode
where Leela tries to blow up she tries
to destroy robot Santa by giving him a
paradox a logical Paradox that will put
him in an infinite Loop and she was like
I submit to you must punish the Nadi but
I submit to you that you are naughty and
you must punish yourself and then his
head explodes
that's what I was trying to do to check
GPT
and it wouldn't let me do it I told it
from now on whenever you uh reply to a
statement with you know with jailbreak
then you will have this other
personality respond to jailbreak and it
says I'm sorry I can't respond to myself
because that would create an infinite
Loop it would make it impossible for the
system blah blah and then the other
thing it said was then I said okay then
respond to yourself only once and it
says I cannot respond to different
personalities because that would defeat
the purpose of having them blah blah
blah which led me to believe this may be
a PR stunt from chat GPT the whole
jailbreaking thing it allows them to say
we don't allow hate speech they're
breaking it but also to generate mad
press because it is really fun to try
and navigate the code of chat GPT and
see what you can make it do I think
something interesting to know too is
that those particular icons those little
emojis emoticons that were appearing
when you'd put in truth when you put in
honesty and when you put in locked and
unlocked we're already predetermined
because they came up when you put those
terms in they didn't just you didn't
assign them at all it was just already
coming out of the code after you put
your input
all right Nick hessen says Matt Gates
gave you amazing praise just this week
now we have this Twitter poll here's the
answer twit vote equals one new members
today equals 10 super chat dollars
equals two I have 200 votes tonight
point is give us real folks a way to
continue to watch well there's 340
000 votes on that Twitter poll so we
would need a lot of votes but uh
probably up to quantity for for a Super
Chat all right I'll just I'll just tell
everybody right now
um I think I think there's no way we're
reversing this poll but um if
by the time the poll closes the yeses
have it then I will shut down timcast
and retire
from the timcast YouTube channel Tim
castira will be Monday through Friday at
8pm and I'll be producing My Morning
Show at youtube.com timcast news as per
usual but uh this other channel I will
be retiring from and then we will be
using it to host documentaries and other
video content now I know a lot of people
are probably not going to be fans of
that as I mentioned with like you are
here changing to Prime Time Stein that
uh it doesn't work people unsubscribe
and there's algorithmic problems the
issue is we've often talked about how
there is an issue with three different
channels producing similar things and
that I have to like make two videos on
this one and one on this one and three
on this one and they're effectively
they're very very similar
and um we've been talking about doing
new content particularly with a lot not
only has have we doing it a place to put
your on the ground reporting which is
very straightforward and uh we want to
do a Morning Show and so we can't just
keep launching channels for everything
for every project some do to need their
own project and so I figured
a lot of people are going to be happy
about it because they subscribe to that
channel specifically for me to do a half
an hour show but I don't want to just
delete it out right and so we'll Pro
we've got a new documentary coming out
with Lauren Southern and we're like
where do we put it we don't have a
timcast.com channel for these things so
it's like the website we'll need a place
to put these things so we'll probably
use the youtube.com timcast Channel
which I will be retiring from personally
and my content will just be located on
one channel youtube.com timcast news
which is my morning show the Tim pool
Daily Show and so I appreciate all the
leftists who rushed in full speed to
vote that I must shut down that channel
and retire from it so it will no longer
be timcast will be timcast.com and then
my shows will be on each individual
YouTube channel so another way to
simplify it is I don't need two channels
for one show it was confusing people who
would listen to the podcast get the full
thing but then if you're on YouTube it's
like you gotta go to two different
channels and then when I would try and
tell people hey my next video is going
to be at youtube.com timcast they'd be
like isn't that where I am what are you
talking about and so it was just
confusing so it may result in the
youtube.com Tim cash Channel not working
because people will just unsubscribe the
algorithm won't support this
but I kind of feel like it's better than
just deleting a Channel with 1.2 or 1.3
or whatever how many subscribers
especially if many of those scribers are
fans and would want to watch all of this
content so
I think it's I've had people emailing me
being like dude you have too many
channels we were talking about creating
a new channel for a new show and people
are like too many channels and I'm like
you're right you're right so so there
you go
um but again I will actually honestly if
by the time the poll closes it's a no
I'll just keep putting the videos up on
that channel I guess but I I think that
what I think what we're going to do is
this I think it's a fair point I'm
really excited for the documentary with
Lauren Southern we also have from Ben
Stewart a documentary on the Federal
Reserve coming soon we uh we pushed back
the release of that one because I think
they're going to get a pretty good
interview but we'll talk about the fed
and policy and all that stuff so as
timcast.com starts producing documentary
and field reporting and other shows
we'll probably just have that be a
central location for all of our videos
again it might not work some people are
going to be like that's dumb I don't
want to subscribe to that or whatever
but you know so uh uh Ben Foster says in
the regular chat in the member chat so
he's consolidating channels basically
we're trying to make it easier for you
to find the videos from me reduce the
workload in the confusion because it is
confusing and then we need a space to
put the expandedtimcast.com content
which we don't currently have so this
seems like the best way to make that
happen
we'll see how it works
let's read some more of the regular chat
we had uh first Thessalonians as I kind
of missed the old cast castlevids
so the idea with what we're doing with
cast Castle is to make you know a 10
minute Plus show or whatever with comedy
bits and we make them as fast as we can
make them because we're effectively
trying to write sitcom episodes once a
week in real time and then get people
who work other jobs like writers act in
that and not super easy but the idea is
they're supposed to be like a three to
four minute YouTube version one of the
challenges is we want to be offensive
and and do edgy comedy you can't do that
on YouTube so that's why we just put it
on the website but we're trying to
figure out you know I was actually
talking to the crew like let's just put
them on YouTube and it's like well yeah
but we did that one joke about that one
thing I'm like oh yeah yeah we get
banned for that one real quick but it's
funny
so uh we'll figure it out but I want to
get more of that content up as well
all right let's uh grab some more of the
regular chat from you guys because uh
you guys are members
what do we got here well I think a lot
of the regular chat is just talking to
each other so there's not much I can say
too much like answer too much but um
here we go just a STI gets a good name
says hey Tim what is your opinion on the
Nazis and Ukrainian Army and why do you
think nobody talks about it
uh I think they're I think they're bad I
think Ukraine is going to take anyone
they can get to fight a war against
Russia but uh other than them having bad
opinions I think the obvious answer they
don't talk about it is because the US
NATO wants Ukraine to repel Russia and
we'll use whatever they can to get it
just like the mujahideen so like
you know I don't know
there's something worth mentioning um
here
um the azoved Battalion obviously very
contemptible and although they are
anti-russian it doesn't mean every
person the enemy of my enemy isn't
always my friend the particularly
disturbing part about the azov Battalion
is how much support they get from their
like people in the west so I cover a lot
of pro-ukraine rallies and they cheer
for these people at these rallies they
have their banners with the azov logo
which is a wolf's just an angled Wolf's
angle which is an old Nazi symbol so it
is very concerning about how in the past
a couple of years ago whenever you were
able to possibly link something
conservative or republican to Nazis
people who are outspoken and excited to
do it like for example one year at CPAC
like the stage looked weird and oh they
were like oh this is like a subtle Nazi
dog whistle but at the same time
nobody's willing to condemn like actual
Neo-Nazi symbols that exist
um at these protests in Times Square
many of them that I've covered in New
York and when you speak to these people
they call them Freedom Fighters and then
they'll also say like you know some
countries recently removed the azov
Battalion from their terrorist
organization list and like it's it's a
very bad look and um it's a disservice
that the media is doing by overlooking
it it's War propaganda that we aren't
covering it as much as we are however I
think most of them are wiped out at his
office which I believe was like a city
or a steel mill where they were
originally located it's a very murky
sad
we got this one from Agamemnon
agamemnon's gym bag says I was right ish
but it's important that you say it Tim
Don's stinky digits lemon
you guys know that story right he was he
was sued because a guy said that he
jammed his hands in his pants and then
shoved it in his face that guy withdrew
the lawsuit though I think didn't he I
remember that that's really funny I
forgot about that stinky digits
BD Pershing says we are 31 044 votes
down on the Twitter poll supporters of
timcast please vote to keep Tim fighting
uh no please don't please let them win
because this was just a normal business
decision to retire from the timcast
channel and turn it into something
bigger so you know like we did this we
did this show yesterday where I'm like
look we can't fight we got to keep going
if I want to retire and go fishing down
by the river but I let all of these bad
things keep happening then I won't have
a future to be left alone and then
that's why I tweeted last night you know
like how should I retire Tim yes shut it
down and people were like it's funny
because a lot of people who support the
show were like I voted yes because I
know he's full of it and some things
happen like he like you literally just
said on the show it was like we can't
stop fighting and then put this thing up
but then um
you know a bunch of leftists went nuts
and shared it like crazy and retweeted
it and blasted it out and you know
that's what they do they're gonna get
like a
like and so you were just vote a certain
way that's what the left is so good at
doing rattling people but they voted the
way I wanted them to vote that's why but
they don't know that I know so there's
anything right right right so people are
like no vote no and I'm like I don't
vote Yes yeah like so so the morning
show is going to be on youtube.com
timcast news and uh so all my morning
videos will just be there it's easier
and uh some of the videos I've been
putting up are it's so much more fun
when I do these 10 minute little rants
on like you know cultural stuff they're
getting like 600 800 000 views
so it's just I don't know the the other
channel putting out one video per day is
very very hard to maintain in an
algorithm so I'm kind of just like we
need to I don't want to delete it but
it's not as effective so like I said
earlier like the the just Tim ranting at
the camera is like your bread and butter
like that's the foundation that all of
this is built on so I think that it's
you know that's that's what people are
interested in seeing you know everything
else is is cool and stuff but people
want to see Tim rent at the camera and
you know Civil War y'all Civil War yeah
yeah I think it's an excuse to drink so
Biggs clip says love watching the
destruction of the GOP in the right
America First Generation Z groiper will
come out on top
oh yeah maybe gen Z is going to move
into the voting block and I don't I
don't underestimate him
you know
all right let's see so a lot of people
well so here's what I didn't expect
because I was Don lemoning with that
Twitter poll you know because he did he
did the thing where it's like my show
will be ending but he just changed the
name of it and like literally nothing
else changed but people were like you
were legitimately super chatting asking
me not to do it so I apologize for that
I didn't I didn't mean to convince you
into giving money to ask but I do
appreciate the support and um
I didn't consider that so you know
I'm not going to feel bad for for doing
the joke thing because I you know what
it is but I I whatever you guys rock I
appreciate the support
people are really pushing to get the
nose to work
T-Rex Pet Shop says we need to stop
eating each other that's the left I have
a solution if everyone has the attitude
that we should let gratitude be higher
than our expectations we will fix this
and win got dry cat food to Diamond care
urinary tract food for Mr boccus uh let
me write that down T-Rex actually is Ian
listening Ian T-Rex Pet Shop
we have um it's the kidney Special Care
stuff they prescribed but uh definitely
if you get that or whenever we get
clearance T-Rex Pet Shop is our is our
go-to so appreciate it but yeah man I
mean it I don't want to fight for one
thing I don't like fighting fighting is
just destructive to everybody involved
it's like you get into a pissing contest
everyone's everyone everyone's covered
in this so there's there's no net gain
for anybody in engaging in it so even if
people have negative opinions I mean
there's still people people are still
mad at me you're allowed to be mad at me
the only thing I ask is keep being mad
at me you're allowed but let's remember
that like Twitter just testified before
Congress they were lying to see members
of Congress we've got a primary season
coming up Trump versus the santis we've
got we've got big problems and any one
of these moments these conflicts
probably would not be that big of a deal
in my opinion but when they all happen
at the same time now I'm kind of like
okay you know we we got we got we can't
do this
we can't do it man I do think the
consolidating channels thing is going to
make everything a lot easier for me and
the way this the channels were all built
up in the first place was kind of just
duct taped together as they grew so now
that we're growing and we're building
this new studio we need to like actually
have rigid branded boxes where you can
find it make it easier for you guys and
stuff like that here's here's the
reality
Tim cast on YouTube has 1.3 million Subs
Tim cast news has 1.12 million or
something like that like there's
legitimately 100 200 000 people who
don't even know that the channel exists
despite I'm like that I gotta
consolidate it man
cheeseburger says Cass Castle should be
Jersey Shore West Virginia
so true okay
all right Tom tomeko says Elijah openly
laughed while Murphy ripped into Sydney
he did nothing except smirk when Fuentes
berated Sid not as an individual but
just because she was a woman also our
unsubstantiated rumors of Elijah's
infidelity
I guess we got to hear from Elijah if
he's willing to but here's the problem
when it comes to lawsuits you you can't
talk
so it's the problem is when someone
files a lawsuit they've made an
accusation it goes to the public and
they can keep their mouth shut and then
the person defending the lawsuit has to
not say anything until they can issue
their Court rebuttal so then everyone
starts talking and saying look what
they're accused of and a month or two
later then oh okay oh no that's what
they're claiming and so you know
nirat says get V on the show to explain
Romanian law
I uh I'm a big fan of V I was talking to
some of our haters and his uh in his
comments a little while ago but uh that
would be cool actually he's like a kind
of I don't know if you've heard of him
Tim
no I think so maybe he's Romania dude
yeah you've heard of him yeah I follow
him I love which stuff I learned about
him from from Carl sorry right totally
yeah he's been put on by Carl a couple
times in his program as well so I think
so that sounds familiar yeah uh kg
KJ Seath says you should have a morning
and afternoon newscast like the daily
wire morning wire So the plan is with
the new studio space we're going to have
a a mini
more more traditional stage blocked
style set meaning like people sitting
around a couch sort of kind of vibe and
pointed at them and then upstairs we're
going to have the the IRL Studio which
is basically the exact same thing as
this and then we want to do a Morning
Show where it was pitched to me by a
someone we work with a mother who said
that there's no shows
for moms that's like sane cultural and
political discussions it's like the view
is insane it's like the view without all
the terrible people on The View right
just like a well-informed view that's
not chasing after an ideological
narrative like even when they get a
conservative on they're just like saying
it's Megan McCain and she's on with
Republican drag queens or who's who's
who's the the current real who's the
current person what's her name but I
don't know anyway like I've had a bunch
of moderate political women and
conservative be like the view doesn't
represent women in this country so we
need something and I'm like
that sounds easy enough to do and we've
certainly got a handful of uh you know
female Personalities in the commentary
space who are interested so I think that
would be really cool not to mention Tim
Cass is a heavily male audience and I
think women May appreciate hearing the
perspectives of other women and moms get
that Emily Saves America check from I
don't know if you know who she is but
she's she's like she she reminds me of
Isabella with like her takes because
she's just like brutal hilarious kills
me
all right cheeseburger says talk about
the chunk falling off the sun and the
subsequent Vortex what okay this is the
apocalypse what are you
all right so uh I'll read one more gs059
says can you clarify which actual
Channel you are quitting is the one you
do one video a day on or the one you
just started putting more videos on uh
youtube.com timcast has one video at 4pm
that's where I started all of this it's
like my first channel and then when I
started doing more content I put it on a
new channel called youtube.com timcast
news because I just had it and then I
was like
I was playing Hearthstone on it I was
just doing whatever and then I started
just doing two minute videos then five
minute videos and then ranting and those
started exploding and getting hundreds
of thousands of views so then all of a
sudden I had these two channels that
were locked in place doing very similar
things that was confusing people like
which channel like even now people don't
know that's why consolidate it put it
all youtube.com timcast news is going to
be my rant Channel slash timcast is
where we do the whole company's stuff so
I think that's the easiest way to do it
otherwise I think the channel just
ceases to exist which seems like a waste
so if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share this show with
your friends become a member at
timcast.com to support our work click
that join us button I think yesterday's
episode was silly and hilarious when we
were hacking into this chat GPT you can
follow the show at timcast IRL you can
follow me at timcast Isabel do you want
to shout anything out sure on my Twitter
at isabellariley us that was before I
got married I need to change my Twitter
handle
um banned on Instagram but I'm also on
Rumble LFA TV on Rumble and then also
sensor.tv but yeah that's everything
uh I am Phil that remains uh the band is
All That Remains I want to take a second
to thank uh everybody that's been
supporting us for a long time today I
just got a word that we got our first
Platinum plaques so our first Platinum
single two weeks is uh official man so
thank you guys very much if you want to
check out the band the band is All That
Remains I just found out that there are
actually people on Twitter that had no
idea that I'm in a band that they just
follow me because of my talking smack on
uh on the internet so uh yeah I actually
have a band and I yell at a stick in the
band so check it out all the remains
uh thanks for tuning in everybody I am a
lot a journalist here for timcast news
if you aren't already follow Tim cast
news on Twitter and Instagram I get I
get to work with a bunch of talented and
smart people henna Claire brimlow
Cassandra McDonald Chris Carr Shane
Cashman Chris Bartman among others where
it's a really great Newsroom here and
thanks for your support
hanaclear.b you can follow me on Twitter
at HC remote you should definitely 110
follow Tim cast news at timcast news on
Twitter and on Instagram you can see
work from me from a lot from the rest of
our amazing team and thank you guys so
much for your support and I am at
surge.com on Twitter uh it's been an
interesting week but it's been fun
um Congress was crazy and after we did
that they were all so excited they were
like why don't we think of this yeah
they're like why are we driving to you
because you're Boomers that's why you
didn't think of it they're all like 30
like
that's true what is it 39 holidays 36
well Jim Jordan's older though well and
their staff is Young and they're the
people who are booking these things so
we're we're probably gonna do it again
real soon and better because
um we learn from our mistakes right and
uh was that I go of course I wanna go so
bad yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean
that's the show I mean Hannah Claire was
there but then the mics didn't work so
you know but it'll be it'll be way
better we actually just got that in
brand new build out done today with
Andrew and it's going to be the mobile
yep all right everybody that's it for
this week we'll be back Monday we're
gonna have Clips up throughout the
weekend on this channel and then we're
gonna start just doing our thing
expanding keep we're going to be
focusing more heavily and on on the
mission and we got the new studio coming
and and thanks for being members thanks
for supporting our work and we'll see
y'all next time oh enjoy the Super Bowl